Hallo und herzlich Willkommen zum Chaos Radio 213, in dem wir uns heute mit der Fragestellung beschäftigen wollen, was passiert eigentlich hinter eurem DSL-Modem? Und falls ihr euch die ganze Sendung live angehört habt, denkt, Moment mal, das klang aber ein bisschen anders. Ja, uns ist da leider durch ein paar technische Probleme die erste halbe Stunde abhanden gekommen. Jetzt könnten wir es dabei belassen und sagen, na ja, Pech gehabt, ihr steigt jetzt einfach mitten ins Thema ein. Aber wir haben keine Kosten und Mühen gescheut und begrüßen deswegen noch mal für eine neue Aufzeichnung der ersten halben Stunde den Mutags. Schön, dass du das noch einrichten konntest. Ja, da ist ein bisschen was schiefgelaufen, aber nichtsdestotrotz wollen wir das jetzt irgendwie noch ein bisschen aufarbeiten. Hintergrund ist so ein bisschen die Fragestellung, was passiert eigentlich mit den Daten, wenn sie irgendwie unseren Router verlassen haben. Denn das ist so ein Thema, das viele irgendwie so mit einem gesunden Halbwissen kennen. Was passiert denn hinter dem DSL-Router?
Na ja, es ist von Zugangstechnologie zu Zugangstechnologie natürlich vollkommen unterschiedlich. Wir sind jetzt hier im Bereich im Access-Bereich, das heißt, die Daten kommen von dem Kunden erstmal irgendwie zu seinem Internetprovider, zu seinem ISP. Und da gibt es natürlich verschiedene Technologien dafür. Also das bekannteste und das, was es am längsten gibt, ist halt das Telefonkabel. Früher halt unser analogisches Modem, das dann so schön gefiffen und gekreist hat. Und das ging dann über die normalen Doppel-Adern, abgekürzt DAs über Telefonkabel also zur Vermittlungsstelle und von da aus dann weiter zu einem Modem, das irgendwo auf der anderen Seite ist. Das gibt es heute noch ganz, ganz selten, vor allem in Amerika. Und was wir hier in Deutschland häufig oder meistens haben, sind eben DSL-Zugänge. Das ist eine Digital Subscriber Line. Das heißt, da ist alles digital, zumindest was die Datenübertragung angeht. Dann haben wir noch VDSL ist auch DSL. Das ist im Prinzip dasselbe. LTE wäre dann über Funk, sprich über den Mobilfunk. Dann haben wir noch den ganzen Bereich Kabelfernsehen, weil natürlich die Kabelprovider fürs Fernsehen schon Kabel in die Wohnung gelegt haben und man sich gedacht hat, hey, die können wir mitbenutzen. Und dann haben wir noch als großes Thema, wo wir auch ein bisschen drüber reden, werden die Glasfaser, die dann eventuell gleich bis ganz ins Haus gehen kann.
Okay, dann lass uns doch mal systematisch anfangen. Das, was die meisten Leute in Deutschland wahrscheinlich haben dürften, ist ein DSL-Anschluss. Du hast jetzt gesagt, irgendwie Zweitradleitung liegt irgendwie bei den Leuten im Haus und hast auf Amerika gezeigt, das könnte ich sagen, ja toll, bei mir liegt auch nur eine Zweitradleitung. Also inwieweit ist denn da DSL anders als eine reine Zweitradleitung?
Na ja, also USA, das Beispiel, um darauf nochmal zurückzukommen, ist deshalb, das ist ein riesengroßes Land und da haben wir sehr, sehr große ländliche Gebiete, die tatsächlich nur ein normales Telefonnetz einfach da haben und da ist es irrsinnig teuer, Kabel zu den Leuten hinzulegen. Deswegen gibt es da eben noch sehr viele Leute, die auch heute noch über ein 56k Modem ins Internet gehen. Und was macht man beim DSL? Beim DSL hat man eben festgestellt, für die Sprachübertragung, die analog passiert beim Telefon normalerweise, habe ich nur ein ganz kleines Spektrum der Frequenzen, die ich nutze. Das fängt irgendwo so bei 16, 17 Hertz oder so was an mit einem tiefen Bass und geht dann so in die zweistelligen 10er Kilohertz-Bereiche. Also irgendwie so 16 Kilohertz hört man eigentlich schon nicht mehr und da ist der Gebührenimpuls für die analogen Gebührenzähler. Mit sehr, sehr guten Ohren hat man das früher gehört. Da kam dann so ein Impuls und jetzt hat der Gebührenzähler weitergezählt zu Hause. Und alles, was da drüber ist, hört man nicht, braucht man auch nicht zum Telefonieren. Und die Bereiche werden eben genutzt, um da Daten aufzumodulieren. Und das ist dann DSL. Das heißt, ich habe dann so eine Frequenzweiche an meiner TAE-Dose hängen, also an dieser Telefondose, die einerseits für das DSL-Modem alle relevanten Frequenzbereiche rausfiltert und glaube, die auch so ein bisschen filtert, dass sie nicht Richtung Telefon durchgeht, um das Störungen zu verhindern.
Aber letztendlich ist das dann wirklich eine reine Zweiradleitung?
Das ist erstmal eine Zweiradleitung, die von meiner Dose über den Verteiler im Keller geht, dann irgendwann bei einem KVZ rauskommt, das ist ein Kabelverzweiger, das ist so einer dieser grauen Kästen, die man so an Straßenrand sieht. Da werden wir heute auch noch ein bisschen mehr drüber reden über die ganzen grauen Kästen, die es da so gibt und was da so drin ist. Das ist so der einfachste Fall. Ich habe einfach solche Klemmleisten, die nennen sich LSA-Leisten, da kommt das Kabel aus jedem Haushalt an, ist auf so einer Federleiste und ich kann über ein Stückchen Kabel, das ich da reinstecke und fest tackere, eine Verbindung herstellen auf ein dickes Bündel Kabel, das zum HVT geht. Der HVT ist der Hauptverteiler, das sind meistens so unauffällige kleine Bungalows, wo dann die Telefonleitungen von ganz vielen Orten zusammenkommen oder von einer Stadt, von einem Stadtbereich, von einem Überzirk zusammenkommen. Davon gibt es relativ viele, verteilt über die Stadt, in kleineren Städten gibt es halt dann so ein, zwei davon, der kann dann durchaus auch schon mal drei bis fünf Kilometer entfernt sein von dem Haushalt, das heißt, wenn ich zum Beispiel reingehe, wo meine Eltern wohnen, da gibt es dann ein Telefonkabel, wo der ganze Ort dran hängt, das geht dann durch einen Wald und irgendwo in der nächsten Stadt ist ein HVT und das ist auch der Grund, warum die nur 768 Kilobit DSL bekommen.
Das heißt letztendlich, da wird die komplette Kupferstrecke ausgeführt und neben dem Telefonsignal sofern noch, ich glaube, wenn ich das richtig mitbekommen habe, wird mittlerweile auch Telefonie dann über DSL abgewickelt bei den neueren Anschlüsse.
Bei den neueren versucht man das ja.
Genau, aber prinzipiell wird da einfach dann das Signal aufgeteilt in ein ganz normales analogisches Sprachsignal oder auch, falls noch jemand den ISDN-Anschluss hat, glaube ich, wenn ich nicht falsch liege.
Genau, der hat benutzt halt andere Frequenzen, das heißt man braucht einen anderen DSL-Standard, der eben die ISDN-Frequenzen freilässt, sodass sie sich nicht ins Gehege kommen. Das ist, glaube ich, eine XJ oder sowas und da habe ich aber wirklich ein Kupferkabel, das vom Haushalt bis in den Hauptverteiler in HVT geht. Das heißt, wenn ich da jetzt meine Steckdose anschließen, 32 Volt draufjage, geht dann irgendwo in der Vermittlungsstelle was kaputt.
Ja, nicht so destruktiv, nicht so destruktiv.
Früher konnte man auch so Batterien damit aufladen. Es gab so Schalterungen, die man da anschließen konnte und dann...
Ja, das ist doch zum Beispiel ein praktischer Hinweis. Naja, das heißt also Batterienladen auf Kosten des Telekommunikationsanbieters ist heute auch nicht mehr. Dafür dann die spannende Frage. DSL haben wir schon gehört, da sind die Datenraten teilweise so ein bisschen unterirdisch. Jetzt hat die Telekom da natürlich oder auch andere Mitbewerber etwas im Angebot. Das klingt erstmal genauso, hat aber ein V vorne dran, das VDSL. Jetzt könnte man sagen, das ist ein anderer Standard, das ist genauso aufgebaut, nur mit mehr Bums. Aber das stimmt so nicht ganz.
Na erstmal stimmt das. Wir haben eine Sache beim DSL jetzt noch nicht besprochen. Das ist nämlich der sogenannte DSLAM. Das ist die Digital Subscriber Line Access Multiplexer. Das ist das Ding, was dann die Daten da rausfuddelt aus dem Kopf war. Einerseits dann die Sprachsignale ganz normal in die Vermittlungsstelle weitergibt, dass man noch mal telefonieren kann. Das ist entweder ISDN oder Analog. Und auf der anderen Seite so einen Datenstrom da auskoppelt.
Mit anderen Worten, das ist quasi genau das Gegenteil von dem Splitter beziehungsweise von dem DSL-Modem auf meiner Seite.
Genau. Was dann darüber passiert ist, man spricht eben so ein Protokoll, das nennt sich PPP-OE, also PPP über Ethernet.
Muss man aber nicht, ist nur in Deutschland so.
Das ist in Deutschland so, weil in Deutschland ist da so, dass ich einen Bit-Stromzugang habe, das heißt die Daten, die aus meiner DSL-Leitung rausfallen, im HVT, aus dem DSLAM, werden dann von da aus in einem Tunnel eventuell zu meinem Provider weitergeschickt. Das hatte man früher häufig bei, ich glaube, 1&1 war das. Die waren ein Reseller, das heißt man hatte zwar einen Vertrag über 1&1, aber das Internet kam über die Telekom und die haben dann die Daten weitergeschaufelt an 1&1. Und da werden dann ganz viele Tunnel gebaut und die Daten weitergereicht. Deswegen haben wir da PPPoE, wo auch eine Authentifizierung drüber passiert.
Das heißt, es geht nicht mehr darum, was mein Hausanschluss ist, sondern es geht darum, welche Authentifizierung ich über diese PPPoE-Verbindung schicke. Das heißt, sobald ich irgendwo anders DSL-Zugang habe, könnte ich den mit meinen Benutzerdaten rein theoretisch genauso benutzen.
Soweit ich weiß, wenn das in derselben DSLAM rauskommt, ja, die sehen aber natürlich, von wo aus die Logins kommen und versuchen, auch missbar zu erkennen. Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt meine Zugangsdaten kopiere und woanders parallel ins Inhead gehe oder sehr häufig über falsche alte Orte, werden die das merken und den Account auch sperren irgendwann.
Okay, aber noch mal, wir haben jetzt gesagt, VDSL ist im Prinzip das Gleiche wie DSL. Aber naja, warum haben wir es jetzt noch mal als separaten Punkt hier aufgenommen?
Beim VDSL merkt man so als Benutzer, dass erstmal die Bandbreiten höher sind. Das fängt glaube ich bei 50 Megabit an. Und was man da gemacht hat ist, man hat diesen DSLAM eben näher zum Kunden gebracht. Ich habe ja früher gesagt, bei meinen Eltern, die haben dann da irgendwie 768 Kilobit und zahlen für 16 Megabit. Und das Problem ist, dass einfach die Kabelstrecke zwischen dem Haushalt und dem HVT oder dem DSLAM zu groß ist. Das sind irgendwie drei oder vier Kilometer. Wenn man jetzt diesen DSLAM irgendwie näher in Richtung Kunde bekommt, dann ist ja Kupferanteil kürzer, also das Kabel ist kürzer. Und man kann mit anderen Technologien zu dem DSLAM hingehen. Das ist das, was man bei VDSL macht. Das sind diese etwas größeren Kästen, die man in Berlin eigentlich an jeder Straßenecke mittlerweile sieht.
Das sind die mit den Lüftungsschlitzen, nicht wahr?
Genau, das sind die mit den Lüftungsschlitzen, die jetzt auch, wenn es so warm ist, wie jetzt während wir hier die Nachaufnahme machen, doch durchaus nachts mal ein bisschen Lärm machen, weil da drin ist aktive Technik mit Lüftern. Und was da halt passiert ist, ich hab halt meinen KVZ, den kleinen Kasten, wo die Telefonleitung auf dem Haushalt kommt. Was ich aber mache, an der Stelle habe ich eine größere Kiste drüber gesetzt und habe in dieser Kiste den DSLAM direkt neben diesen KVZ gesetzt. Das heißt, das Ding, was aus dem Kupfer digitale Signale auf Glasfaser macht, und da komm ich gleich dazu, ist dann schon direkt am Bürgersteig, am Curb oder im Cabinet. Das heißt, ich bin näher mit dem DSLAM am Kunden und kann jetzt diesen DSLAM oder diesen VDSL-Verteiler mit einer Glasfaserleitung anfahren als Provider. Und das ist deswegen besser, weil ich über Glasfasern zum einen wesentlich längere Strecken überbrücken kann und zum anderen mit wesentlich höheren Bandbreiten operieren kann.
Ok, das heißt, letztendlich rückt die Glasfaser so ganz langsam irgendwie an den Kunden ran. Aber warum liegt sie denn auf der Straße? Warum liegt sie nicht bei mir im Keller oder bei mir in der Wohnung?
Tja, das ist eine gute Frage, die glaube ich auch sehr schnell sehr politisch werden kann. Wir haben in Deutschland einen ganz komischen Telekommunikationsmarkt, wo es so einen ehemaligen oder noch Monopolisten gibt, der die letzte Meile im Wesentlichen kontrolliert. Und es ist halt sehr, sehr viel Geld in meinen Kupferausbau gesteckt worden. Das merkt man auch jetzt bei den Vectoring. Es wird irgendwie nicht gerafft, dass man mal in Glasfaser investieren sollte und Glasfaser eigentlich bis in die Wohnung haben möchte.
Warum sollte eigentlich irgendwer inklusive dem ehemaligen Staatskonzern investieren? Das ist ja generell so ein bisschen das Problem, wenn ich das so beobachte. Also nicht nur in der Telekommunikationsindustrie, aber generell, die den Anreiz richtig Kohle in irgendwas Langfristiges reinzustecken, also in neue Infrastruktur, die jetzt quasi nicht auf was weiß ich Kupfer basiert, was ja im Wesentlichen abbezahlt ist und was jetzt eigentlich nur noch Geld macht. Der Anreiz ist doch sehr, sehr klein letztendlich, auch mit dem, wie es im Moment politisch gehandhabt wird.
Richtig, der Anreiz ist sehr klein, auch weil wir so ganz komische politische Vorgaben haben, dass ein Breitbandanschluss in Deutschland, ich glaube, bei 1 Megabit oder bei 2 Megabit anfängt.
Das heißt, es gibt eine garantierte Breitbandabdeckung politisch, aber die wird einfach sehr gering definiert.
Richtig, und wenn man sich natürlich den Durchschnitt anguckt, also die durchschnittlich verfügbare Bandbreite und die dann nur erreichen muss auf der Fläche, dann habe ich natürlich als Provider, der da irgendwie kontrolliert wird oder reguliert wird, durchaus so einen Anreiz, naja, die in der Fläche gering zu halten, damit ich nicht in der Fläche ausbauen muss. Das heißt, wenn jetzt andere Provider ankommen und die Bandbreite nach oben jagen, müsste ich das eventuell auch tun und das will ich nicht, also blockiere ich die anderen Provider. Und natürlich Infrastruktur zu legen in der Form ist unheimlich teuer und eigentlich müsste man da eine Infrastrukturmaßnahme auflegen, die tatsächlich Leerohr oder Glasfaser in die Häuser legt, so wie es ja früher bei dem Kupfer auch passiert ist. Und es ist tatsächlich schwierig zu vermitteln und zu verstehen, warum ein einzelner Provider jetzt Kabel legen soll in jeden Haushalt. Warum man da nicht sagt, wir haben halt irgendwie so eine Netzgesellschaft, die irgendwie vielleicht gemeinnützig ist oder ähnliches, die dann gefördert wird vom Staat und da eben einfach Infrastruktur, die dann zu vernünftigen Preisen an auch kleinere ISPs vermietet wird, zur Verfügung stellt.
Okay, letztendlich ist es aber ein rein deutsches Problem. Weißt du, ob das im Ausland da andere Modelle gibt?
Es scheint da zum Beispiel in der Schweiz auch ein ganz anderes Modell zu geben. Da bekomme ich für ein paar hundert Franken oder weniger. Ich weiß den Preis jetzt nicht mehr auswendig. Das war relativ günstig. Pro Jahr einen symmetrischen Glasfaseranschluss. Da gibt es noch mal mindestens zwei Sachen, die wir erklären können oder sollten. Prioritiere 50 Gigahertz Technik, das kenne ich auch aus dem Arburger Raum. Da gibt es ein riesengroßes Becken und in der Mitte ist ein ehemaliger Vulkan. Das ist natürlich für Funk ideal. Da sind ganz viele kleine Dörfer drin, die ein bisschen verstreut sind in diesem Amüneburger Becken. Die Stadtwerke haben sich gesagt, da kann man was machen. Die haben an den Rand und zwischendurch Funkmasten aufgestellt und verteilen von da aus Internet in die Dörfer. Das ist eine dörfliche Region. Da ist man durchaus in der Lage, auf sein Dach zu klettern und am Antennenmast eine kleine Antenne anzubringen. Die richtet man aus Richtung dieses Funkmastes. Darüber gibt es dann Internet. Man muss sich über einen anderen Provider das Telefon dazukaufen.
Das andere ist natürlich das, was jetzt in aller Munde ist, LTE.
LTE wird momentan stark ausgebaut, dieser gesamte Internetzugang über Mobilfunk. Wir sehen, dass das Frequenzen, die bisher anders genutzt wurden, jetzt dem gegeben werden. Das sind zum einen die Frequenzen, die für so Sachen wie Bühnenmikrofone und Rückkanäle für die Schauspieler genutzt wurden. Dass die jetzt plötzlich genutzt werden für LTE. Das heißt, jemand sitzt mit einem LTE-fähigen Handy im Hörsaal in der Uni und plötzlich fällt das Mikrofon vom Professor aus. Das haben wir jetzt relativ häufig. Das Gleiche gilt für das analoge Fernsehen. Das wird jetzt nach und nach abgeschaltet. Geht Richtung DVB-T. Da gibt es jetzt die Nachfrage DVB-T2, damit die Frequenzen frei werden. Damit eben diese ganzen Frequenzen, die für den Mobilfunk interessant sind und benötigt werden, um mehr Bandbreite hinzukriegen, da zur Verfügung stehen. Das Problem dabei ist aber, dieser ganze LTI-Kram ist ein sogenanntes Shared Medium.
Darf ich dich da nochmal ganz kurz einhaken? Du hast gesagt, da werden Frequenzen frei, in dem Sachen abgeschaltet werden, soweit klar. Und dann werden Sachen frei, weil man auf eine neuere Technologie geht. In dem Fall hast du gesagt DVB-T, das ist das digitale terrestrische Fernsehen, und DVB-T2, das kann man vielleicht nochmal kurz erläutern, soweit wie ich das verstanden habe. DVB-T2 hat einfach unter anderem effizientere Übertragungsart, setzt auch zumindest in Deutschland auf einen neueren Videocodec, nämlich H265 statt H264. Und dadurch ist einfach letztendlich die Bandbreite, die dort benötigt wird, etwas geringer.
Aber sie gehen eben auch mit der Frequenz glaube ich höher, wodurch für die Mobilfunkprovider Frequenzen mit mehr Reichweite frei werden.
Das heißt, die Mobilfunkprovider hatten ja bisher immer das Problem, sie sind auf sehr hohen Frequenzen gewesen, irgendwie 1800, 1900, so was um den Dreh für LTE, wenn ich richtig informiert bin. Das ist zwar irgendwie ganz schick, um viel Daten zu übertragen, aber das ist weniger schick, wenn man ein bisschen Reichweite hinkriegen will und seine Zellen gerade auf dem Land ein bisschen weiter auseinander haben will.
Genau, kann man sich vielleicht ein bisschen erklären. Langwelle, das Radio, ist eben das, was über Kontinente quasi geht. Die U-Boote benutzen längst Wellen, um die Reichweite eben möglichst hoch zu haben. Und der ganze UKW-Kram ist eben doch örtlich sehr begrenzt von der Reichwerte her.
Okay, das heißt, damit hätten wir dann auch LTE-Abgefrühstück?
Mit einer Ergänzung. Was jetzt vermarktet wird, ist ein LTE im Bundle mit DSL. Die Provider haben festgestellt, DSL ist überlastet. Ich hab irgendwie meine Telefonleitung, die hat nicht so viel Bandbreite, weil es ist halt eine alte, vielleicht mit Papier umwickelte, schlechte, 80, 100 Jahre alte Zwei-Draht-Kupferleitung, die da irgendwo hingeht, die seit über 100 Jahren im Boden liegt und vor sich hin rottet. Und je mehr Nachbarn da irgendwie noch DSL bekommen, umso mehr hab ich da vielleicht Störungen drauf. Und so abends ab 18 Uhr ist das DSL auch irgendwie tot, weil viel zu viele Leute das benutzen. Also sagen die Telcos, Mensch, in solchen Spitzenzeiten schieben wir die Leute auch aufs LTE rüber. Das heißt, es gibt spezielle Router, die haben einen DSL-Anschluss als auch LTE. Und dann schaltet man doch eben rüber auf das LTE oder fängt eben Spitzenspitzen, Lastspitzen, Trafficspitzen.
Ist das ein exklusives Umschalten, oder gibt es quasi Bitstrom auf beiden Medien?
Das kommt drauf an. Technisch geht beides, das nennt sich dann Multipath, was zum Teil auch gemacht wird. Ich glaube, Apple, iPhones machen sowas auch.
Sehe ich das als Benutzer, oder wird das Multipath irgendwo abgehandelt?
Das ist komplett transparent. Das Problem, was aber da ist, das DSL ist überlastet, und jetzt schieben wir alle zum LTE, und plötzlich ist die LTE funktiell überlastet, weil LTE ist auch ein Shared Medium eben auf der Luft. Und da sind im Zweifelsfall noch viel mehr Leute drauf als auf dieser einen Kupferleitung.
Das heißt, was wir sehen werden, ist Provider gehen auf LTE, weil der Ausbau für LTE billiger ist. Und irgendwann, wenn alle das geglaubt und gekauft haben, werden sie feststellen, dass mit Luft man irgendwie nur so und so viel kriegen kann. Und vielleicht besteht dann so ein bisschen die Hoffnung, dass man doch auf Glasfaseraufbau bis zum Endkunden, na ja, mal schauen, ob das irgendwie Realität werden kann. Schauen wir mal, was wir jetzt noch ausgelassen haben. Ich nehme mal an, so den Teil DSL und LTE haben wir jetzt abgefrühstückt. Genau, dann kommen wir nämlich jetzt noch zu einem anderen Medium, das sich schon über eine ganze Weile sehr populärer...
Beliebtheit erfreut.
Beliebtheit erfreut, genau. Nämlich das Kabelfernsehen zum Internet machen. Da muss ich jetzt erstmal sagen, okay, Kabelfernsehen kenn ich. Das war in den 80er Jahren irgendwie mal der große Hype um analoge Fernsehsignale über altbackenes BNC-Kabel in die Haushalte zu bringen. Und auf einmal soll ich darüber auch in die andere Richtung senden können und nicht nur ich, sondern auch noch viele andere. Und hä?
Genau, es ist auch wieder ein shared medium, ein ETA, den man sich da teilt. Das heißt, wir haben festgestellt, wir haben doch schon Kabel, die irgendwie durch die ganzen Orte gehen und die in jedes Haus reingehen. Und aufgrund der Art, wie ich das gebaut habe, so ein Kabel, das im Boden liegt, da kann ich verschiedene Sachen drüber machen.
Das haben wir ja genau bei dem alten Zwei-Draht zum Telefonieren auch schon gesehen.
Genau, und hier macht man jetzt Ähnliches. Man hat eben nicht alle Frequenzen im Fernsehspektrum oder in dem Frequenzbereich, wo Fernsehen ist, werden genutzt. Das heißt, man hat auch hier wieder bestimmte Frequenzen, die man nimmt, um darüber Daten zu übertragen. Und was man jetzt halt macht, ich habe das Kupferkabel, dieses Quarks-Kabel, das hat in der Mitte so eine Ader und rundherum ist ein Drahtgeflecht als Abschirmung. Und das liegt jetzt von Kabel-Kopfstationen irgendwie in der Straße bis in die Haushalte und eventuell oder in Berlin nicht unbedingt, aber manchmal sieht man das eben in den Städten, wo es nachgebaut wurde, geht dann so ein Kabel an der Hauswand hoch, da ist da so ein T-Stück und dann geht es wieder weiter. Und hier in Berlin eher sind dann so Kopfstationen, wo dann ein CMTS drin ist, das ist ein Cable Modem mit Termination System und da werden dann in dieses Fernsehkabel, nenne ich das jetzt mal, eben Daten eingespeist für den Internetzugang.
Und letztendlich, ich kann weiterhin Fernseh gucken, ich kann ja weiterhin auch Analog Fernseh gucken, ich kann irgendwie Digital Fernseh gucken, ich kann jetzt aber auch Internet darüber machen. Das heißt, da passiert, wenn ich mir das so richtig vorstelle, sowas ähnliches wie beim DSL, nämlich ich trenne das nach Frequenzen auch.
Richtig, und wer mal dabei war, wie so ein Kabeltechniker einen neuen Internetanschluss konfiguriert quasi oder aufbaut, der öffnet im Keller vom Haus dann so einen Verteiler, da kommt ein dickes Kabel an von der Straße, das geht auf einen Verteiler und dahinter sind dann so Filterstücke und diese Filterstücke bestimmen eben, darf dieser Kunde analoges Fernsehen empfangen, da habe ich nämlich keinen Filter für die Frequenzen, in denen das Fernsehen drin ist, oder darf er eben keinen Fernsehen empfangen und nur Internet, dann baut man da ein Filterstück rein.
Das heißt, man kann da an der Stelle schon sehr viel machen, ohne auch nur irgendwie ein aktives Gerät dazwischen zu haben, das irgendwas bestimmt, sondern das geht rein über Frequenzfilter oder Frequenzweichen.
Na, ich habe halt einen Verstärker im Haus, der Strom braucht und das Signal verstärkt und danach ist halt ein Filter, der dafür sorgt, dass eben Kunden, die jetzt keinen Kabelfernsehen als solches bezahlen, auch keinen Kabelfernsehen empfangen, sondern nur Internetdaten machen können. Weswegen der Bereich, in dem die Internetdaten sind, auch der Frequenzbereich in einem bestimmten Spektrum auf dem Kabel sein muss, um eben am Filter vorbeizukommen. Und von dem Verteiler im Keller geht eben dann in jede Wohnung ein einzelnes Kabel, sonst könnte man eben auch so nicht filtern. Und die Rückrichtung passiert eben dann, indem das Kabelmodem, was man dann angeschlossen hat, selber in das Kabel reinsendet auf eine Frequenz, die für dieses Kabelmodem dann in dem Moment reserviert oder frei ist.
Das heißt, das ist dann ähnlich wie bei LTE Modems. Fangen die Modems mit ihrer Gegenstation, die Gegenstation war die CMTS, richtig? Genau. Die verhandeln erstmal, wo sie überhaupt letztendlich ihren Traffic abwickeln.
Richtig.
Auf welchen Frequenzen?
Das Problem, was wir da aber eben auch wieder haben, ist, auch das ist ein Shared-Medium, das heißt, ich hab ein Kabel, das in ganz viele Haushalte geht. Und je nachdem, wie das Netz ausgebaut ist, können das auch dann schon mal so tausend sein oder so. Und wenn dann so ein Kabelsegment überlastet ist, kann man das auftrennen. Wenn das Kabelnetz einigermaßen neu ist, hat man da auch dran gedacht. Früher in so einem kleinen Ort geht halt ein Kabel durch den ganzen Ort. So in einer Stadt wie Berlin ist es dann so, dass man diese Segmente unterteilen kann und auch durchaus mal kabelparallel liegen, die man dann eben in dieser Kopfstation aufspalten kann, wenn man merkt, dass die Brandweite nicht mehr für alle Kunden reicht.
Gut, das heißt aber letztendlich auch bei Kabelmodems gehe ich nur bis zu dieser CMTS und dahinter ist es doch garantiert letztendlich auch einfach ein Glasanschluss wieder.
Richtig, danach kommt auch einfach Glas. In der Sendung hat man auch noch darüber gesprochen, dass man tatsächlich auch diese gesamten Analogsignale, die da sind, auf Glas direkt umsetzen kann und dann die CMTS ein bisschen weiter weg steht als am Bürgersteig, wo sie eben vielleicht geklaut wird oder beschädigt wird. Aber letztlich kommt das alles dann wieder auf Glas raus. Was auch da passiert zum Teil ist, dass ich die Daten in der CMTS rausziehe und das Fernsehsignal von weiter weghole. Das heißt, das geht dann zu einer eigentlichen Kopfstation für den Fernsehempfang weiter, der da eingespeist wird. Die Daten werden früher schon auf das Glasfaser rausgeführt. Das ermöglicht natürlich, dass ich so einen Hauptkabel habe mit dem Fernsehsignal, dass in verschiedene CMTS reingeht. Und in der Abteil-CMTS ist dann eben die reservierte Bandbreite fürs Internet für die einzelnen Stränge.
Das heißt, jetzt noch mal zusammenzufassen, wir haben die Zugangstechnologien DSL mit dem Spezialfall VDSL. Und wir haben uns Kabel angeguckt. Und in beiden Fällen jetzt das LTE mal außen vor gelassen, da wird dann wahrscheinlich die Umsetzung auf Glasfaser meistens an den Funktürmen stattfinden.
Ja, die viele Funktürmer haben tatsächlich einen Glasfaseranschluss, der da hochgeht. Das ist häufig bei der Telekom so, weil sie ein eigenes Glasfasernetz hat. Andere Provider wie Vodafone klassischerweise haben eigene Richtfunkstrecken, zum Teil zwischen den Masten. Sieht man immer an diesen kleinen runden Antennen, die in eine bestimmte Richtung zeigen. Und meistens dann in die Richtung von einem anderen Mast. Das kann zum Beispiel eine Straße hinwechseln über eine breite Hauptstraße, weil auf beiden Seiten ein Teil von der Funkzelle ist. Oder eben weitere sogenannte Backholes, die dann zu dem Kernnetz vom Pro-Weiler-Richtung in die Richtung führen.
Okay, dann mal von der Richtstrecke jetzt abgesehen. Wir sehen aber schon, dass die Glasfaser letztendlich immer näher rückt.
Richtig, das läuft unter diesem Stichwort FTTX.
Genau, dann erklär doch mal Wieso X.
Was man eventuell schon mal gehört hat, ist Fiber to the Home, FTTH abgekürzt.
Das ist das, was quasi die Nerds so predigen. Ich möchte gerne irgendwie meine Glasfaser direkt in den Router reinstecken können.
Genau, nicht in den Router rein, weil die ist empfindlich und zerbricht. Aber ich hätte gerne irgendwie Glasfaser bis in meine Wohnung. Und zwar nach Möglichkeit auch eine Glasfaser, die nicht beschaltet ist in der Form. Das heißt, die nicht von einem speziellen Provider abhängig ist, damit ich da eben wählen kann. Und die mir dann ermöglicht, dass ich symmetrisch in beide Richtungen den gleichen Datenverkehr oder die gleiche Bandbreite habe. Und dann haben wir ja bei DSL solche Sachen wie 16 Megabit down und 2 Megabit up oder sowas.
Das ist aber nicht gesetzt, das ist zwar spezifiziert, aber letztendlich könnte ich das auch anders fahren. Ich könnte das symmetrisch fahren, ich könnte genau umgekehrt fahren. Das ist einfach nur das, was mir mein Provider verkauft.
Genau, das ist das, was die Provider momentan verkaufen. Auch weil sie zum Teil keinen Bock haben, ihre Netze richtig auszubauen.
Und weil sie natürlich auch gerne wollen, dass du das große Besteck an Tarif einkaufst, wenn du einen ordentlichen Upstream haben willst.
Genau, Fiber to the Home war das eine. Ich möchte also das Glasfaser bis direkt in mein Zuhause haben. Da habe ich dann natürlich im Prinzip gar keinen Kupfer mehr dazwischen. Das nächste wäre Fiber to the Building. Das heißt, ich habe irgendwo im Keller meinen Glasfaseranschluss, kann da eventuell auf Kupfer gehen und das dann hoch in die Wohnung legen. Weil Kupfer noch ein bisschen robuster ist, ist das wahrscheinlich auch die Sache, die ich erwarte, die sich verbreiten wird. Wenn ich mir so ein Hochhaus denke und der Vermieter hat dann Glasfaser in die Wohnung, ich glaube, die werden relativ häufig kaputt gehen, wenn man sie nicht richtig, richtig gut einpackt. Das nächste wäre dann Fiber to the Curb oder Fiber to the Cabinett. Das ist im Prinzip das, was man bei VDSL macht. Ich habe eben solche grauen Kästen, die mit Glasfaser angefahren werden. Zum Teil auch mit Glasfaser, das dann so 30-40 cm unter der Oberfläche ist und in einem Schlitz im Bürgersteig verlegt wird. Das machen sie jetzt verstärkt, weil das einfach sehr günstig zu verlegen ist. Natürlich in der Hoffnung, dass dieser Bordstein dann so bald nicht mehr saniert wird und jemand mehr Wasserleitungen legen möchte oder so. Das nächste ist eben Fiber to the Neighborhood. Das heißt, ich habe irgendwo in der Nachbarschaft eben dann zum Beispiel so diesen HVT oder sowas. Da geht dann zwar ein Glasfaserkabel hin, aber das kann tatsächlich ein paar Kilometer weg sein.
Also Neighborhood ist da schon sehr großzügig auszulegen. Ich habe mich hier mal gefragt, was ist Curb und was ist Neighborhood? Also Neighborhood kann auch sein, das ist im nächsten Dorf, wo es halt den HVT hat.
Musst halt amerikanisch denken.
Gut, das heißt, wir haben jetzt einmal einen Rundumblick bekommen. Wie kommen die Daten von Modem, vom DSL-Modem, vom Kabelmodem oder auch über LTE zum Anbieter? Wir haben gesehen, das involviert sehr viel Glasfaser. Wir haben gesehen, weil Glasfaser so blöd zum Kunden zu führen ist und weil man da so etwas wie Geld ausgeben muss, müssen wir ja irgendwie zusehen, dass wir das alte Kabel möglichst noch nutzen. Und haben gesehen, da gibt es dann so etwas wie LTE oder sogar alte Zugangstechnologien oder vermeintlich alte Zugangstechnologien, muss ich eher sagen, wie Kabel. Weil ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, Kabel kam mir immer sehr 80er vor, bis es dann irgendwann in den letzten fünf Jahren so wieder aufgeploppt ist als Zugangstechnologie.
Na ja, du kannst halt die Bandbreiten im Prinzip so hochlegen, wie du wenige Kunden auf dem Kabel hast. Das heißt, wenn die jetzt anfangen 200 Megabit darüber anzubieten oder sowas, heißt das, dass sie die Kabelstränge halt kurz machen müssen, damit die Bandbreite noch über das Kabel geht zu den Kunden hin oder auch zurück. Und deswegen ist das eigentlich eine relativ schicke Sache, weil über dieses Coax-Kabel kann ich eben durch die Schirmung, die rundherum ist, sehr hohe Frequenzen übertragen.
Sonst würde das wahrscheinlich auch gar nicht funktionieren in der Art und Weise. Gut, dann bleibt nur noch eine Frage, nämlich, wenn wir denn so gerne Glasfaser hätten, dann müssten wir jetzt mal drüber reden, gibt es irgendwie doch Interessenten, die so Glas verlegen, dass wir dann vielleicht doch irgendwann mal direkt entweder Fiber to the Home oder zumindest to the Building nutzen können. Also wer hat eigentlich ein Interesse daran, Glasfaser zu verlegen? Sind das nur Telcos oder gibt es da sogar noch andere, an die man so gar nicht denkt?
Es gibt da eine ganze Reihe von Anbietern, von Institutionen oder von Firmen, die das so nebenbei ein bisschen mitmachen, zum Teil weil sie es für ihr eigenes Geschäft brauchen, zum Teil aber auch weil sie erkannt haben, dass sie damit sich ein bisschen Nebeneinkommen sichern können. Das sind zum Beispiel Verkehrsbetriebe. Wenn man sich anguckt, die BVG in Berlin zum Beispiel, die so ein Tunnelnetz hat, die haben da eben Glasfaser drin liegen, weil sie selber Glasfaser brauchen, um ihre Anzeigetafeln und die Fahrkartenautomaten und den ganzen Kram anzusteuern. Und die BVG hat tatsächlich mehrere parallele Ringe liegen, sodass auch wenn dann in einem Tunnel mal so ein Zug entgleist und die Kabel aus der Wand reißt, über die andere Richtung immer noch der Verkehr laufen kann. Sowas passiert halt häufig. Wir haben auch bei den Tramlinien parallel Glasfaser liegen, weil auch da natürlich Ticketautomaten stehen, die irgendwie sagen sollen, wann sie nicht mehr funktionieren und die vielleicht auch irgendwelche Werbung anzeigen sollen oder Updates kriegen sollen. In so Städten wie Marburg, wo ich ursprünglich herkomme, gab es früher von der Feuerwehr so Brandmelder, die dann irgendwo an einem Straßenrand standen, wo man draufdrücken konnte und dann kam halt die Feuerwehr dahin. Da haben sie gemerkt, Mensch, da haben wir irgendwie Rohre, die dahin gehen, lass doch Glasfaser reinlegen.
Diese, ja?
Das passiert halt in einigen Städten, auch in Nürnberg zum Beispiel, das heißt, man kann von der Feuerwehr zum Beispiel Glasfaser kriegen.
Und die würden das dann providerneutral zu einem Standardtarif anbieten?
Na ja, man kann sich da zumindest als Provider eine Standleitung mieten. Energieversorger machen das auch gerne. Die Hochspannungskabel oder Hochspannungsmasten, die haben oben so ein Erdkabel drin, wo der Blitz einschlagen kann. Aber dieses Kabel ist allerdings leer, das ist hol. Und da sind mittlerweile Glasfasern eingezogen. Und das ist auch die Art und Weise, wie das Camp in diesem Jahr an sein Internet kommt. Es gibt halt ein Glasfaserkabel, das oben in diesem Erdungskabel drin liegt, das alle paar hundert Meter oder alle paar hundert Meter im Prinzip mal den Maß druntergeführt wird, wie er nach oben geht. Da ist dann so eine Kabelmuffe dran und da kann man dann eine Glasfaser anschließen und darüber Internet bekommen, wenn auf der anderen Seite auch jemand eine Glasfaser anschließt.
Haben die auch konkrete Anreize jetzt dafür, das zu legen? Oder ist das auch nur, vielleicht können wir da ein Nebengeschäft machen?
Zum einen steuern die darüber ihre ganzen Umspannwerke und ihre Schaltwerke. Die brauchen also ein eigenes unabhängiges Netz, das auch bei einem Stromausfall im Land noch funktioniert. Das heißt, die wollen da nicht angewiesen sein auf andere. Und dazu brauchen die das. Und wenn sie sowieso schon dieses Kabel da liegen haben und austauschen und warten müssen, dann können sie sich eben darüber auch noch ein Zusatzgeschäft sichern und finanzieren damit ein Teil ihrer Infrastruktur, was das angeht. Das sieht man aber auch bei Pipeline-Bauern. Irgendwelche Öl- und Gaspipelines, da reißt man sowieso den Boden auf. Dann wirft man auch noch so eine Glasfaser mit rein, weil das ist an sich nicht teuer, da so ein Leerrohr oder so eine Faser sogar reinzulegen. Und die kann man dann entweder einzeln halt verkaufen, indem man sagt hier, ich propagiere das so zusammen, dass du auf der einen Seite mit dem Laser reinleuchtest und auf der anderen Seite kommst du raus. Oder man teilt sich so eine Glasfaser, aber das besprechen wir glaube ich auch im späteren Teil nochmal.
Falls ich jetzt doch mal ein bisschen mehr Internet brauche, als die Telekom mir offiziell anbieten will, was ist denn dann so, also an Trassenpläne komme ich ja wahrscheinlich eher nicht ran, so als normalsterblicher.
Genau, Trassenpläne sind so ein bisschen geheim, weil sie natürlich Angst haben, dass jemand die Kabel aus dem Boden reißt, um da irgendwie einen Anschlag zu machen oder sowas, keine Ahnung. Was man aber machen kann, ist, wenn man mit so ein bisschen offenen Augen durch die Stadt läuft, sieht man eben nicht nur diese KVZ, diese Kabelverzweiger. Wenn man mit gesenktem Kopf ganz demütig rumläuft, dann sieht man immer solche Kanaldeckel, wo dann so komische Namen draufstehen, sowas wie Colt oder Telekom oder sowas. Und da liegen dann Glasfasern drunter.
Das heißt, das sind diese viereckigen Schächte?
Genau, die sind verschieden groß, es gibt da so ganz kleine. So 30 x 30 oder 40 x 40 cm. Da liegt im Prinzip dann nur so eine Muffe drin, wo man dann wieder eine Glasfaser dranspleißen könnte, um von da aus ins nächste Gebäude zu gehen. Die gibt es aber auch in größer, wo man dann als ganze Person runterklettern kann und dann mehrere so riesengroße, armdicke Muffen drin hat.
Will heißen, wenn ich einen vergleichsweise kostengünstigen Anschluss haben möchte, Glasanschluss, dann wäre es am sinnvollsten erstmal mit den Firmen zu reden, dessen Name irgendwie bei mir vom Büro oder in der Straße vom Büro auf dem Bürgersteig steht. Okay, dann vielen Dank bis dahin. Und wir machen gleich weiter nach einer kleinen Musik und dann wieder live on tape. Chaosradio 213, viel Spaß! Wenn... Harry? Hallo willkommen zurück im Chaos Radio immer noch mit Kai mit Mutags und mit einem spontan verschwundenen Nibbler, der hoffentlich gleich noch mal wieder kommt. Und wir haben in der ersten halben Stunde so ein bisschen besprochen, wir haben so ein bisschen besprochen, wie wir jetzt eigentlich vom DSL Modem oder auch irgendwie vom Handy, das per LTE angemeldet ist, zu unserem Anbieter kommen, aber wir sind noch nicht ganz da. Und das wollen wir jetzt besprechen. Wir gehen jetzt Richtung, steht hier im Vorbereitungspad, Backbone. Wer mag das mal erklären?
Also wir haben jetzt da so einen Provider, der kriegt jetzt meine Daten und der muss damit irgendwas tun. Jetzt kann der sich nicht einfach so bei der Telekom so ein DSL klicken. Das heißt, was der halt in der Regel macht, ist, er baut sich ein Netzwerk auf mit angemieteten oder mit eigenen Kabeln, die im Boden liegen, und verbindet damit halt seine, ja, die Stellen, wo er diese DSL-DSLAMs hat, die die DSL-Anschlüsse von den Endkunden zusammenführen. Das ist in der Praxis noch mal ein bisschen anders, weil der DSLAM gehört dann der Telekom und das wird dann untervermietet. Und dann wird dann nur der Bitstrom, das heißt nur die Daten werden dann da irgendwie weitergereicht. Aber das klammern wir jetzt einfach mal aus, weil da können wir glaube ich zwei Stunden drüber erzählen alleine.
Ich komme später noch mal darauf zurück, falls ein Thema was gehen.
Das heißt, ich habe halt diesen Datenstrom, der wird zu einem Rechenzentrum oder in einem Location, in einem Ort von dem Provider transportiert. Und der muss jetzt diese ganzen Orte, wo er seine Kundendaten aggregiert, miteinander vernetzen und das dann irgendwie ins Internet transportieren. Und dazu hat er eben eine eigene oder angemietete Glasfaserkabel, die diese Pops oder diese Orte verbinden. Und damit hat er erstmal sein eigenes Netzwerk und den Traffic von seinen Kunden da drin.
Okay.
Und Backborn kann halt sehr klein sein, das kann irgendwie, naja, so ein kleiner Provider um die Ecke sein. Das kann aber auch irgendwie über ganze Ländergrenzen oder über Staaten hinweggehen.
Dann wäre jetzt die Frage an Kai, weißt du, wie das in der Praxis tatsächlich ist?
Also dieser Backborn setzt sich eigentlich in der Regel immer aus sogenannten Pops zusammen, was einfach Points of Presence sind. Die gibt es in verschiedenen Klassifikationen. Je nach Größe des Providers gibt es halt Core, Super, Cable, Regional, sonst was Pops.
Okay.
Aber prinzipiell ist so ein Pop immer so ein mehr oder weniger ein Rack, mehrere Racks, wo Routing-Equipment drin steht oder Switcher, also da, wo diese ganzen Kabel ankommen. Und da sind auch Devices drin, die wissen, wo das Paket weiter geschickt werden muss und vor allem, wie man das weiter schickt. Und das sind einfach große Kreuzungspunkte, wo man Pakete von A nach B schicken kann. Und zum Beispiel so ein DSLAM oder das Paket von zu Hause kommt halt immer erst in so einen Pop. Und dann versucht man das halt zusammen zu aggregieren und sich auf diesen großen Backbone, den man dann gebaut hat, zu legen.
Und du musst auch noch unterscheiden, Backbone ist... Also Backbone gibt es unterschiedliche Arten. Wir sind jetzt gerade von der Richtung Endkunde oder Firma gekommen. Sprich, ich hab da Daten von Nutzern. Eine andere Richtung Backbone sind eben Provider, die selber keine Endkunden in dem Sinne haben, aber die wieder Provider für andere Provider sind. Das heißt, die haben dann zum Beispiel eine Leitung über den Atlantik und bieten anderen an, für sie Daten zu transportieren von A nach B.
Das einzige, wo ich euch jetzt gerade noch ein bisschen verloren habe, ist, ihr habt gesagt, wir haben eine Kupferstrecke oder eine Kabel- also Quark-Strecke, wir kommen dann da irgendwie auf Glas und auf einmal sind wir auf irgendwelchen Routern. Gleichzeitig haben wir irgendwie gesagt, es geht zu Sachen wie VDSL, wo wir gesagt haben, da steht schon Providerzeugs in der Straße. Wo befinden sich diese Pops tatsächlich? Befinden die sich in der Straße? Befinden die sich im HVZ?
Also diese größeren Pops in der Regel stehen in Rechenzentren, weil das sind dann Router, die ziehen dann da auch gerne mal so 2 bis 6 kW und sind so 2, 3 Meter hoch fast und füllen so ein komplettes Rack aus.
Wäre jetzt vielleicht für die Straßenecke ein bisschen groß?
Genau, das ist nicht nur ein bisschen groß für die Straßenecke, die sind auch ein bisschen teuer und die will man dann in eine Gegenstellung, die so ein Rechenzentrum ist, wo es dann auch Zutrittskontrollen gibt mit Klimaanlage, Strom ist immer da, mit Batterie und Diesel versorgt, falls der Stadtstrom ausfällt. Und da stellt man die dann halt hin. Und das sind halt primär Rechenzentren, die gibt es halt mehr oder weniger in allen Größen, von ganz kleinen in Städten, wo es halt manchmal in so einem großen Kabelknotenpunkt mit drin ist. Aber es gibt dann halt auch zum Beispiel in den größeren Städten wie Berlin, Hamburg oder auch Frankfurt gibt es halt wirklich ganze Gebäude oder Straßenblöcke, die halt wirklich nur aus Rechenzentren bestehen, wo sich Firmen darum kümmern, dass Klimaanlage, Strom und so weiter einfach mal da ist.
Und in den Kabelverzweigern und in dem, was auf der Straße oder im HVT ist, ist eben nur Technik, die dafür da ist, die Umsetzung zu machen von der Kupferader auf Glasfaser und die Sachen weiter zu transportieren. Das heißt, diese ganze Authentifizierung von den Passwörtern, die ich auf DSL eventuell habe, diese PPPoE-Sessions und so weiter, das endet dann alles auf der anderen Seite eben in so einem Pop. Und da stehen auch die Server dann, die das verarbeiten können, die Accountdaten prüfen können und dann eben den Zugriff erlauben oder auch nicht.
Das heißt, wir sind jetzt im Rechenzentrum oder in diesem Pop drin. Da wollen wir aber nicht bleiben.
Da wollen wir nicht bleiben. Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt so ein ISP bin und ich habe ganz viele Endkunden, die dann YouTube und Google benutzen wollen oder Twitter benutzen wollen, muss ich mich halt darum kümmern, wie kommen denn meine Daten oder die Daten meiner Kunden dahin, bzw. wie kommen die Daten von YouTube oder von, ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie andere heißen, gibt es da noch andere? Wie kommen die zurück zu meinen Kunden? Und da kommen wir dann politisch irgendwann auch vielleicht eventuell Richtung Netzneutralität, was aber auch ein Riesenkurs, den wir heute Abend überreden wollen.
Aber irgendwie muss doch das Paket erst mal weiter Richtung kommen, weil YouTube ist nicht in Berlin, glaube ich.
YouTube ist auch in Berlin, aber das haben wir dann vielleicht hinterher noch, wenn wir bei CDNs sind. Ich muss mich halt darum kümmern als ISP, wie komme ich eigentlich in das Internet? Und da müssen wir vielleicht noch mal ganz kurz drüber sprechen, was ist denn das Internet eigentlich? Und das Internet ist ein Netzwerk von Netzwerken. Das heißt, es gibt halt nicht nur so Internet-Service-Provider, die da so ihren Backup-On haben, und diese Transit-Provider, die dann anderen anbieten, Daten zu transportieren, die ihre eigenen Netzwerke haben. Es gibt dann auch irgendwelche Firmen, die dann irgendwie Dienste anbieten, wie zum Beispiel Google oder YouTube. Und alle diese Netze sind autonome Systeme, weil die unter der Verwaltung von einer Entität sind. Das heißt, eine Firma verwaltet so ein Netz oder eine Organisation. Und diese autonomen Systeme haben AS-Nummern, die sind durchnummeriert, diese AS-Nummer muss man beantragen.
Wo beantrage ich die?
Die beantrage ich zum Beispiel beim RIPE in Europa. Das ist das Réseau Internet, Europeen, das ist eine französische Abkürzung, obwohl es in den Niederlanden sitzt. Die verwalten für Europa IP-Adressen und auch die AS-Nummern. Die werden dann global koordiniert. Da werde ich Mitglied und kriege eine AS-Nummer zugewiesen und kann die dann benutzen, um in der Kommunikation mit anderen Leuten im Internet, also mit anderen ASen, mit anderen autonomen Systemen zu sagen, ich habe diesen IP-Bereich zugewiesen bekommen vom RIPE oder von wem auch immer. Und sage alles, was als Zieladresse diese Adressen hat in diesem IP-Bereich, bitte zu meiner AS-Nummer routen. Und dann kommt der Traffic da an, wenn ich den Verbindung mit anderen habe und wenn andere dem zustimmen. Das heißt, ich muss halt irgendwo meine Kabel miteinander verbinden. Und da kommen dann solche Herrschaften, wie der hier rechts von mir oder links von mir für die Zuschauer ins Spiel. Das sind dann Internet Exchange Points zum Beispiel. Früher war es halt so, ich musste zu einem großen Provider hingehen, der ein globales Netz hatte und da für Geld mein Internetzugang kaufen quasi als Firma oder als ISP. Und hab dann da ein Kabel hingelegt. Und man hat dann irgendwann festgestellt, naja, wir haben jetzt hier so ein Data Center und da hocken wir sowieso alle zusammen. Und warum müssen wir jetzt den Traffic, den wir untereinander austauschen, unsere Kunden untereinander austauschen, warum müssen wir den eigentlich teuer über so ein Uplink abwickeln? Wir können doch ein Kabel direkt zwischen unseren Racks spannen. Und das wurde tatsächlich dann sehr viel gemacht. Daraus sind dann so Internet Exchange Points entstanden. Und da kommt dann so ein Community-Gedanke her. Das heißt, die Leute treffen sich abends beim Bierstellenfest und unsere Kunden tauschen eigentlich ganz schön viel Daten untereinander aus, dass wir ein Kabel legen. Und das ist dann institutionalisiert worden. Das heißt, man hat dann irgendwo zentral einen großen Switch hingestellt. Alle haben sich dann da angeschlossen. Und wenn man dann ungefähr gleich viele Daten in beide Richtungen austauscht, macht das halt echt Sinn, dass man da halt kostenlos quasi die Daten austauscht miteinander. Das wäre dann Open Peering, so genanntes. Und man braucht halt solche Peering Points, um sich zusammenzuschließen. Und daraus entsteht dann das Internet.
Moment, genau. Peering Points, da kommen wir gleich glaube ich noch drauf. Jetzt habe ich aber diese AS-Nummern. Und unabhängig davon, wie ich jetzt mit anderen Netzen, wenn ich euch richtig verstanden habe, zusammenkomme, wie geht denn das? Also jetzt unabhängig davon, wie ich mich jetzt mit anderen Leuten zusammenschließe, woher weiß ein anderer Provider oder ein anderes autonomes Netz, wie es mit mir umzugehen hat? Oder woher weiß irgendwie ein Provider in China, was ich jetzt anzubieten habe?
Na, da wird dann primär dieses Protokoll BGP benutzt, was für Border Gateway Protokoll steht. Das ist nichts anderes als mehr oder weniger, dass ich meinem Rechner sage, dass er mit deinem reden soll. Und du sagst deinem Rechner, dass er mit meinem reden soll. Und dann hat sich so eine Session aufgesetzt, also eine sogenannte BGP-Session. Und die ist dann, die sagt dir dann einfach, da sag ich dir dann so, hallo, ich bin der Kai. Und bei mir sind folgende IPs zu haben. Und du sagst mir, hallo, ich bin der Danimo. Und folgende IPs sind bei mir zu finden. Und wenn das jetzt ganz, ganz viele Leute machen, dann baut sich da halt so ein vermaschtes Netz auf, wo Leute miteinander vernetzt sind. Und je nachdem, was die auf dieser Session konfigurieren, nennt man das Ganze dann halt eine Uplink- oder Transit-Session oder einen Peering. Weil ein Peering ist zum Beispiel, dass es halt wirklich direkt zwischen zwei Providern ist und nur zwischen den zwei Providern. Während ich, wenn ich zum Transit gehe oder einem Carrier, dann kaufe ich halt einmal sozusagen das gesamte Internet ein. Weil wenn ich jetzt ein Kabel zu Google werfe und mit den Peer, kriege ich halt nur Google und niemand anders. Aber ich brauche natürlich auch noch den ganzen Rest vom Internet. Zum Beispiel Yahoo und Bing und so weiter.
Moment, ich versuche das mal gerade in so einem Bild zu sagen. Das eine ist so ein bisschen wie die direkte Auffahrt, die ich mir irgendwie zu meinem Nachbarn theren lasse. Und das andere ist mehr so der Autobahnanschluss, der mich überall hinführen kann.
Na das eine ist so das Türchen im Zaun, um schnell zu deinem Nachbarn zu kommen und die Straße zu benutzen. Und das andere ist halt eher so ein Navigationssystem, was dir ins Auto hängen kannst, damit du weißt, wie du in die nächste Großstadt oder Übersee kommst.
Und im Idealfall hast du eben nicht nur eine Leitung in das Internet zu den anderen, sondern mehrere. Und gerade für solche Sachen ist dann eben dieses Border Gateway-Protokoll wichtig. Warum? Na ja, es gibt da so Dinge, die nennen sich Bagger. Und so ein Bagger, der dann so eine Glasfaser aus dem Boden zieht, der unterbricht dann halt so ein paar tausend Verbindungen gleichzeitig. Und dann ist halt nichts mehr mit Internet und mit YouTube. Und dann sind die Kunden böse und dann laufen die weg. Und dann fragen sie sich, warum die eigentlich Geld bezahlen.
Das einzige, was mich jetzt wundert, so BGP, hab ich jetzt schon mal gehört, haben möglicherweise noch nicht die meisten gehört.
Also nicht verwechseln mit PGP, das ist was anderes. BGP ist eben das Border Gateway-Protokoll, was ich dann mit anderen spreche und ich innaunze dann meine AS-Nummer zusammen mit den Netzwerkpräfiken, also die IP-Adressen, die mir zugeteilt sind.
Soweit klar, aber das ist jetzt irgendwie nicht so was, was ich und du machen. Nibbler, du bist mittlerweile wieder da und hast auch wieder ein Mikro, das hoffentlich funktioniert. Ah, willkommen zurück. Machst du BGP?
Weil es geht.
Dann erzähl mal dein News-Case.
Na ja, wenn man an dem Internet teilnehmen möchte, dann kann man sich da halt an einen Provider anschließen oder selbst Teil des Internets werden. Letzteres ist halt spannender. Das funktioniert so, das Internet besteht aus ganz vielen Routen. Inzwischen sind das über 500.000 zu den einzelnen Rechnern, die am Internet angeschlossen sind. Und wenn du eben dieses BGP mit einprichst, dann hast du auf deinem Router keine default-Route mehr. Das heißt, du hast nicht mehr den einen Punkt, wo deine Pakete hingehen, sondern nimmst an dieser ganz großen Wolke teil und weißt eben, das Paket muss da hinten hin, das muss da hin. Das ist auch ein Unterschied zwischen einem Transit, also einem Anbieter, der einem das ganze Internet gibt. Von dem kriegt man dann die Information, du hast jetzt hier diese 500.000 Routen, für die kannst du mir Pakete schicken. Und ein Peering ist, du hast hier die 2-3 Routen, schick mir bitte nur für diese Routen Pakete.
Da gab es noch irgendwie einen Spezialbegriff, den Kai irgendwie in seinem Vortrag hatte.
Genau, weil das sozusagen eine Zone ist, in der es keine Default-Grute gibt. Deswegen nennt man die Default Free Zone. Beziehungsweise DFZ kurz gesagt. Das ist halt so, da wo das Internet stattfindet, weil zu Hause sagt man halt, alles was nicht lokal ist, schick mal dahin. Aber wenn man halt in dem Internet mit BGP so teilnimmt, da gibt es halt kein zentrales Ding, wo man alles hinschicken kann, das findet das.
Na doch, die NSA.
Ja, ne, die schickt auch die Pakete nicht weiter.
Die schaut nur drauf.
Genau, die macht nur eine Kopie.
Wenn ich jetzt nur an Transit-Provider hänge, bin ich dann in der Default Free Zone? Oder ist das dann immer noch ein Default Gateway, auch wenn ich mehrere Transit-Provider habe?
Wenn du mit Ihrem BGP sprichst, dann bist du Teil der Default Free Zone. Also es definiert sich dadurch, dass du nicht eine Default Route oder zwei Default Routen hast. Wenn du zwei Carriers hast, wird es schwierig, weil du irgendwo deine IP-Adressen haben musst. An dem Moment, wo du keine Default Route mehr hast über deinen Uplink, bist du Teil der DFZ. Es gibt natürlich auch, dass man sagt, man holt sich nur zwei Carrier und nimmt an dem ganzen Peering nicht teil, weil man irgendwo auf dem Land ist oder sonst wo. Aber eben den Anspruch hat, möglichst unterbrechungsarmes Internet zu haben, dann hat man eben eine, zwei oder drei Carrier.
Also kommt halt ganz drauf an, was man will. Dieser Punkt ist halt, dass man, wenn man jetzt einen Server irgendwo hinstellt und sagt, ich hab eine IP, dann hat man null Kontrolle über das Netz. Man kann nicht entscheiden, wo man den Treffigien checkt. Man hat wieder diese sogenannte Default Route und das war's dann sozusagen. Das hört dann da auf. Mehr kannst du nicht entscheiden. Wenn du BGP hast, und zum Beispiel zwei Provider hast, die dir eine sogenannte Fulltable schicken. Fulltable heißt, du kriegst 560.000 Routen aktuell, wo dann das ganze Internet drin ist. Da kannst du zum Beispiel echt sagen, du schaust dir halt beides an. Nur weil du zum Beispiel siehst, es ist halt der Pfad, aber in diesem BGP-Protokoll ist nicht enthalten, wo der Pfad so wirklich langgeht. Das kann halt sein, da wird nur entschieden, wie viele Netzwerke dazwischen sind. Aber nur weil zwei Netzwerke auf dem Weg sind, heißt das jetzt nicht, dass der Trafik lokal in Deutschland bleibt, der kann auch in Amerika ausgetauscht werden. Und da kann man dann über BGP halt wirklich sagen, ich hätte jetzt gerne zum Beispiel das Telekom-Netz über den Uplink A, weil der hat eine gute Konnektivität zur Telekom, während das Netz zu Kabel Deutschland bitte über Uplink B gehen soll, weil der hat eine tolle Connection mit denen. Und da kann man wirklich den Trafik wirklich viel feiner steuern dann auch.
Also die Informationen, die man zu den Routen bekommt, setzt sich so zusammen. Man selbst nimmt seinen IP-Adressbereich, wirft den in dieses BGP rein und dann propagiert der sich durchs Internet. Und jedes Mal, wenn der eine AS-Grenze überschreitet, also von einem Netzbetreiber zum nächsten gereicht wird, hängt der an diesem Pfad seine AS-Nummer an. Du siehst also, wie viele ASs dieses Announcement, also diese Erklärung, ich habe hier diese IP-Adressen, auf dem Weg durchlaufen hat über die Fahrtlänge. Kannst du anhand der Fahrtlänge schätzometrisch sagen, na, das kommt von weiter weg, ich nehme mal lieber den, wo weniger drin sind, das muss wohl näher sein.
Das heißt, ich nehme da zwei Dinge quasi mit. Das eine ist, so ein Router braucht verdammt viel RAM, um das zu halten. Weißt du ungefähr, wie viel?
Naja, das kannst du nicht mit RAM in deinem Computer vergleichen, weil so ein Router ja Pakete weiterleiten muss. Das heißt, er muss auf den RAM sehr spezifisch und schnell zugreifen können. Und ja, das ist schon...
Also die einfachen Router, es gibt da zum Beispiel so ein Butter- und Brotprodukt von diversen Herstellern, da wird halt das Routing wirklich in Software gemacht. Da ist dann halt bei 700 Megabit Schluss, auch wenn die Kiste viermal ein Gigabit hat. Da kann man dann so viele Routen reinstecken, wie Ram da ist und da ist gerade so eine Fulltable, so 700 Megabit glaube ich, äh Megabyte.
Das Problem, was diese 700 Megabit beschränkt ist, dass für jedes Paket der Router ja nachgucken muss. Und wo muss dieses Paket hin?
Na, der Hacken ist vor allem, da muss die CPU nachschauen auf solchen Routern. Während auf einem großen Router, der zum Beispiel eine Backplane von einem Terabit hat, wo wirklich viele Pakete deutlich mehr als diese 700 Megabit durchgehen, da muss dann halt wirklich, da ist das in Hardware gebaut. Also da ist dann wirklich ein Chip drin, der halt Pakete wirklich viel schneller und einfacher entscheiden kann. Also das ist so ein bisschen vergleichbar mit einer Autobahn-Kreuzung.
Umgekehrt vor allem mit einer Grafikkarte.
Anstatt zu einer...
Moment, Moment, der Mutags explodiert da gerade hinten.
Wir haben gerade so fünf Fachbegriffe benutzt, die wir alle noch nicht erläutert haben.
Deswegen versuche ich das gerade mit einer Analogie zu erklären.
Wir haben noch nicht mehr erklärt, was eine Route eigentlich ist.
Ja, eine Route ist halt ein Wegweiser zu einer IP-Adresse.
Genau, ich habe also, eine IP-Adresse existiert nicht alleine, sondern die ist Teil eines Netzwerkes. Von zuhause kennt man dann sowas wie 192.168.1.0 und dann steht dahinter sowas wie 1.24. Das heißt, ich habe 24 Bit von dieser Zahl, die das ist. Und darüber kann ich dann eben sagen, wohin Daten geschickt werden sollen. Und diese Router announceden eben, dieser Netzbereich ist bei mir, das ist eine Route.
Okay.
Das ist der eine Punkt. Backplane hatten wir gerade eben. Das ist das in einem Router, was die verschiedenen Anschlüsse miteinander verbindet und wo wirklich die Daten drüber gehen. Und wenn die halt langsam ist, dann kann der Router auch nicht so viel Daten transportieren.
Das heißt, das ist dann schon wieder spezielle Hardware?
Na, um den Analogie vielleicht fertig zu machen, um das Ganze auch verständlich zu haben. Also man kann halt zum Beispiel sagen, es kreuzen sich zwei Straßen. Und wenn sich zwei Straßen kreuzen, kann man da halt so eine Ampel hinstellen, die jetzt einfach mal die CPU signalisiert. Da kann man auch links, rechts geradeaus fahren. Allerdings muss man halt immer warten und sich genau einordnen. Während so eine Autobahnkreuzung, da macht man dieses Einordnen halt über so einen Kilometer und nimmt dann halt die Kurve auch bei 120 kmh. Und so ähnlich ist, wenn man dieses Routing in Hardware macht. Da kann halt dann wirklich ein spezieller Chip, so ein Paket lesen und weiß dann, wo das hin muss, ohne da jetzt jedes Mal relativ viel Rechenaufwand reinzustecken, sondern der macht das einfach nebenher. Und da kann dann einfach viel mehr an Datenverkehr durchgehen.
Da hast du dann auch nicht 2, 3, 4 Spuren, sondern die laufen übereinander und untereinander und überhaupt.
Und letztendlich Datenverkehr austauschen, schön und gut innerhalb eines Rechenzentrums. Zwischenrechenzentren miete ich mir dann immer selber eine Faser, lege ich selber eine Faser, was mache ich da, um sowohl innerhalb des Rechenzentrums als auch irgendwie zwischen den Rechenzentren kommunizieren zu können, was macht man da üblicherweise?
Also zwischen deinen Rechenzentren kommt ganz drauf an, wo deine Rechenzentren zum Beispiel stehen. Nur zum Beispiel in der Stadt, wenn das jetzt in Berlin ist, du willst zum Rechenzentrum A, zum Rechenzentrum B in Berlin, da sind dann vielleicht 5 km Luftlinie dazwischen. Da mietet man sich tatsächlich eine Glasfaser mit so ein Pärchen, da ist dann komplett leer.
Da kannst du auf der einen Seite reinleuchten und auf der anderen Seite leuchts wieder aus.
Genau, da kümmert so ziemlich keiner drum, was du machst. Da kannst du meinetwegen auch SPDIF drüber fahren und halt deine Boxen ansteuern.
Stopp, SPDIF ist Digital Audio.
Digital Audio mit einem Laserpointer über Plastikkabel in der Regel. Das kann man da auch drüber fahren. Aber du kannst halt auch ganz, ganz viele Daten drüber machen, sodass wir plötzlich über Terrabit reden. Das ist im Idealfall, was man in der Stadt macht. Und jetzt so eine einzelne Faser über das Land zu verlegen, wo wir dann so über 400, 500 Kilometer Strecke reden, ist dann halt natürlich sehr viel aufwendiger. Und da kommen dann auch ganz andere Dinge rein, weswegen man dann sogenannte Wellenlängen mietet.
Ich wollte gerade schon fragen, weil du da sagst, Terrabits über Faser. Ich kenne ja kein Interface, über das man ein Terrabit bekommt.
Da ist doch alles Zeigenkabine.
Die Wellenlängen sind tatsächlich das, was man auf der Langstrecke macht. Aber das macht man natürlich auch in der Metro, also in der Stadt sozusagen, weil eine Faser kann halt ein Signal übertragen. Aber man will halt viel mehr darüber machen, weil das jetzt eine ganze Verschwendung ist. Weil zum Beispiel ein Signal ist ein Gigabit. Und für jedes Gigabit, sich ein Glasfaser zu mieten, das wird dann relativ teuer. Und dann müssten ja viel mehr Glasfasern gebaut werden.
Das heißt, ganz kurz, es gibt zwei Spiele, weiß nicht. Ich kann entweder eine Farbe, das heißt einen Wellenlängenbereich nehmen. Man kann also so einen Faser mit mehreren Wellenlängen gleichzeitig bespielen, wie Licht halt so ist, richtig?
Genau, das ist dann einfach eine Art von Multiplexing, sogenanntes Wave Division Multiplexing, was halt am Ende ist da ein kleiner Prisma drin, der weiß, dass halt gewisse Wellenlängen, Farben, also Farben wirklich nennt man das halt auch in der Regel eine Colored Wave, Colored Optik, dass halt diese Farbe auf den Port 1 muss und die andere Farbe auf den Port 2. Und dann hat man zwei so Geräte an beiden, an jedem Ende, also ein Gerät pro Ende. Und dann schickt man zum Beispiel auf Port 1 eine bestimmte Farbe rein und die kommt am anderen Seite an Port 1 raus. Und dann gibt es halt die Geräte, die haben halt nicht nur ein Port, sondern 48 Ports oder 96 Ports. Sprich, man kann da zum Beispiel 48 verschiedene Farben drauf machen, die am anderen Ende 48 mal rausfallen. Und so kann man halt relativ hohe Kapazitäten über eine wirkliche Glasfaser dann erreichen.
Mit anderen Worten, eine Glasfaser, die ich komplett selber bespielen kann, ist entweder nicht möglich oder geht in Richtung unbezahlbar, wenn man sie nicht selber besetzt.
Das kommt drauf an, wie lang sie ist. Also zum Beispiel in der Stadt machst du das in der Regel selbst. Da kostest du 1.500 Euro im Monat, wenn man da jetzt so die erste Mal kauft. Auf einer Strecke wie von Berlin nach Frankfurt reden wir da plötzlich über 20.000 bis 30.000 Euro im Monat. Wenn du dann tatsächlich von Europa nach Amerika willst, dann musst du da wahrscheinlich ganz am Anfang mehrere Millionen reinwerfen, damit du eine davon kriegen kannst. Dann wird die mitgebaut beim nächsten Mal.
Wie komme ich nach Amerika? Da ist jetzt relativ wenig Land zwischen Europa und Amerika?
Genau, da liegen auch wieder Glasfasern. Die sind eigentlich genau die gleichen, wie sie auch hier in der Stadt liegen. Nur, dass die ein bisschen besser verpackt sind. Da ist dann halt diverse Schutzmechanismen drin, damit wenn das jetzt zehn Jahre über ein Stein scheuert, nicht gleich ein Loch drin ist. Also hat man da so einen dicken Stahlmantel drum. Dann hat man auch wieder so relativ wenige Paare. Aber tatsächlich sind da so zwölf Paare zum Beispiel drin. Und die sind dann halt 5000 Kilometer lang.
Was kann ich dann darüber verfahren, über eine dieser Paare?
Da ist halt dann wieder eine Frage, was du an diesen Multiplexing Equipment da reinsteckst. Also es gibt welche da... Ja, es ist tatsächlich wenig, aber mit aktuellen Multiplexing kriegt man da halt mehrere Terabits ohne Probleme drauf. Und da werden halt die Geräte einfach teurer. Aber dafür hast du halt viel genauere Laser, wo man viel mehr Laser, viel enger aneinander auf viel weniger Wandbreite packen kann. Und dadurch kann man halt dann mal eben einen Terabit da drauf packen. Aber das kostet halt deutlich mehr. Deswegen macht man das in der Stadt nicht, weil da ist die Faser wiederum günstiger.
Mit anderen Worten, wenn es teuer ist, dickere Leitungen zu legen, dann ist es billiger, einen dicken Kompressor an beide Seiten zu packen, die da ordentlich Daten durchjagen. Um das mal so ganz grob zu übersetzen.
Genau, das spielt nur ein anderer Punkt rein. Also zum Beispiel in der Stadt kommst du halt einfach so aus, da ist ein Laser stark genug. Aber bei 5000 Kilometern reicht jetzt so ein Laser halt nicht aus. Also nimmst du diesen Mantel, da ist ja Metall drin, den du zur Schutz vor der Umwelt benutzt. Und dann packst du einfach Strom da drauf. Dann hast du alle 100 oder 200, 300 Kilometer einen Verstärker drin. Und wenn du dann halt einfach mal 1000 Fasern reinmachst, musst du da halt 1000 mal verstärken. Und dann brauchst du halt viel mehr Strom. Und das macht das Ganze halt auch Platz. Und das macht das Ganze dann schwierig. Deswegen werden sich in der Regel auf irgendwie so kleine Faseranzahlen beschränkt. Weil das kann man ohne Probleme vom Land aus auf das Kabel speisen. Und dann hängt da halt irgendwie 20, 30 Repeater auf dem Kabel. Und die funktionieren dann alle noch. Und die sind dann auch nicht so riesig groß. Weil man einfach für zwei Faser nicht so viel Platz braucht. Und auch nicht so viel Strom.
Das heißt, drum landen so Fasern, wenn sie an der Küste entlang gehen, auch öfters mal an. Zum einen, um da abzugreifen. Also um einzelne Fasern aus dem Bündel herauszunehmen. Um Teilstücke von dieser Faser zu benutzen. Alles auch zum Wiederauftanken.
Das heißt, Seekabel sind nichts anderes als ein sehr spezialer Spezialfall der ganz normalen Faser. Das heißt, damit sind wir dann auch durch den Teil durch. Und dann müssten wir uns jetzt mal angucken, jetzt wissen wir wenigstens, wie unsere Daten irgendwie bei anderen Anbietern ankommen. Aber was sie dann machen, wie wir dann letztendlich da unsere Webseite kriegen, das haben wir noch nicht besprochen. Und das machen wir in der nächsten Stunde des Chaos Radio. Danke für's Zuhören. So, und wir sind zurück im Chaos Radio. Die letzte Stunde von zwei zu Gast sind die Herren Kai.
Hallo.
Nimla.
Und Mutaks. So, und wir haben gerade besprochen, wie denn Daten von meinem DSL-Anschluss oder von meinem Handy jetzt irgendwie dann mal in Rechenzentren anlanden.
Und dann sind sie schon fast am Internet.
Wieso fast?
Na ja, ich glaube, wir haben das vorhin schon kurz angerissen, das mit dem ganzen Carrier und auch dem Peering. Deswegen ich jetzt gerade ein bisschen ratlos bin, weil ich was man jetzt noch erzählen soll als nächsten Punkt, weil wir die Timelines zerstört habt.
Wir haben dir die Timelines zerstört? Nein, nein, nein.
Das steht noch diverser Kram.
Diverser Kram. Und da kommt auch noch. Da gibt es einiges, was nämlich der Mutags unbedingt noch besprechen wollte.
Ach du Schande, ich?
Ja, du. Und aus der Nummer kommst du nicht mehr raus.
Weißt du noch, was das war?
Ja, du wolltest mir zum Beispiel erzählen, was es mit DNS Anycast auf sich hat.
Ach du Schande.
Du wolltest was über CDNs erzählen, du wolltest was über DDoS Protection erzählen. Aber fangen wir doch mal ganz ruhig an. In unserer kleinen Vorbereitung hier und auch in dem Titel der Sendung haben wir gesagt Cloud, Cloud, Cloud, Cloud. Wir sind jetzt aber in einzelnen Datenzentren.
Die Cloud klaut meine Daten. Na dazwischen ist noch eine ganze Menge anderes. Ich hab halt irgendwelche Dienstlieder laufen müssen, damit das alles funktioniert. Und an einem Dienst kann man vielleicht noch ein bisschen erklären, was du vorhin gesagt hast, dieses Anycast zum Beispiel. Wir haben ja im Internet so Hostnamen und Webseiten, die haben so Namen wie www.google.com oder www.youtube und so weiter. Das muss ich auf IP-Adressen umsetzen, damit dann eben so was wie der Router überhaupt die Daten transportieren kann. Das heißt, ich hab meinen Rechner, geb da irgendwie die Adresse von der Webseite in meinem Browser ein und muss das übersetzen. Das mach ich mit DNS-Servern. Die sind weltweit verteilt und so ein bisschen sortiert. Das Problem daran ist, wenn man jetzt da so einen oben drüber hätte oder hat, der so die sogenannte Root-Zone verteilt, das heißt, wenn ich jetzt www.google.com auflösen möchte auf eine IP-Adresse, dann teile ich diesen Namen erstmal in einzelne Bestandteile auf und fange von rechts an, das heißt, ich habe das Punkt COM, das ist die Top-Level-Domain COM. Die kommt aus den USA und dann muss ich mir erstmal einen Nameserver suchen, der weiß, wen muss ich denn fragen für alle Namen unterhalb vom Punkt COM? Das ist die sogenannte Root-Zone oder die Root-Nameserver. Wenn ich da jetzt so einen einzigen habe, dann ist der sehr schnell sehr überlastet.
Das ist richtig, dann stelle ich doch einfach mehr dahin.
Dann stelle ich einfach mehr davon hin, aber dann müsste ich ja an die Leute verteilen, welche Adressen die alle haben. Das wird dann irgendwann sehr kompliziert, weil die ändern sich dann und dann ist das doof. Und wenn so ein Host immer nur eine Adresse hat, dann kann ich den ja immer noch überlasten, weil ich habe ja dann diese eine Adresse von diesem Host, dann schiebe ich alles dahin und ich kann ja nicht verhindern, dass alle Leute die selbe Adresse nehmen. Ist das aber so ein Problem, wenn ich dann die selbe Adresse mehrfach verwenden möchte, dann gibt es halt Probleme normalerweise. Also kann jeder zu Hause mal ausprobieren, ich nehme zwei Rechner, schließe sie an das Kabel an und gebe ihnen die selbe IP-Adresse.
Stell dich mir jetzt ungut vor. Aber warte mal, warte mal, warte mal, wir hatten doch vorher dieses BGP, hat das? Ich bin auf dem richtigen Weg.
In der 4th-Zone oder im Internet können wir eben einen Trick anwenden. Wir sagen einfach, naja, es gibt mehrere Rechner, die selber IP-Adresse haben, die stehen aber nicht im selben Data Center, sondern weltweit verteilt. Und per BGP announce ich jetzt dasselbe Netz und dieselbe IP-Adresse. Ein prominentes Beispiel ist die Nameserver, die Google so für jeden anbietet, die 8888 und die 8844, die haben halt diese beiden IP-Adressen.
Du musst das jetzt wie auf Ritz machen, weil du hast jetzt hier eine Person genannt, also eine Firma und dann muss man natürlich auch die Alternativen nennen.
Kennst du die IP-Adresse von OpenDNS zum Beispiel?
Es gibt auch noch die 194, 150, 168, 168.
Oder die 141, 111 von OpenWireless und das davor war von AS250. Und da gibt es auch noch DNS-Cash Berlin CCCDE.
Ich muss jetzt einfach sagen...
Die IP-Adresse, dafür könnt ihr euch im DNS abholen.
Ich muss trotzdem sagen, sorry Leute, die 888 kann ich mir deutlich besser lernen. Ja, ich gebe zu, ich gebe zu, convenience, sie kriegen mich, sie kriegen mich. Dafür habe ich kein Gmail. Doesn't matter.
Okay, also wir haben eine IP-Adresse, ABCD, oder AAAA, 888, ach egal. Und ich habe jetzt mehrere BGP-Router, die diese IP-Adresse, dieses Netzwerk annoucen. Das heißt, die sagen alle, hier bei mir kriegst du diese IP-Adresse, hier bitte die Daten hinschicken. Wir haben vorhin so ganz kurz am Rande erwähnt, wenn ich jetzt so einen BGP-Router betreibe und dann da ganz viele Routen announced bekomme, entscheide ich unter anderem anhand der AS-Fahrtlänge, das heißt anhand der Anzahl an verschiedenen AS, die dazwischen sind bis zum Ziel, wohin ich die Daten schicke. Und normalerweise bevorzuge ich den Fahrt, der am kürzesten ist, weil das geht meistens am schnellsten, der ist am nächsten dabei, Netzwerk-topologisch betrachtet. Wenn ich jetzt aus verschiedenen Richtungen die selbe IP-Adresse announced bekomme, was im Normalfall ja auch der Fall ist, wir haben vorhin gesagt, ich habe mein Netzwerk und ich habe mehrere Ablink-Provider, ich piere also an mehreren Stellen, da announce ich ja auch in jede Richtung die selben IP-Adressen. Weil ich möchte ja von überall die Daten bekommen. Das heißt, es ist der Normalfall, dass ich immer mehrere Wege zum Ziel sehe. Und das macht man sich jetzt dazu zu nutzen, indem ich halt sage, naja, das muss nicht das selbe Ziel sein. Ich habe verschiedene Stellen, die dieselbe IP-Adresse announceen und die, die am nächsten bei mir dabei ist, die bekommt eben den Traffic und kann mir auch antworten. Weil meine IP-Adresse ist ja eindeutig.
Noch mal ein Versuch, da einen Vergleich zu ziehen. Das heißt, das ist so ein bisschen wie stille Post aus verschiedenen Richtungen. Und da wo es...
Das ist so ein bisschen wie wenden sie sich an die nächste Polizeidienststelle. Da ist ja auch nicht gesagt, welche, sondern heißt nur wenden sie sich an die nächste Dienststelle.
Dann wärst du die 1, 2, 2 und dann kommst du bei deiner nächsten 1, 2, 2 Stelle raus.
Das heißt, jedes Mal wenn ich den Google DNS Server anrufe, ist das so ein bisschen so, als wenn ich die Polizei anrufe?
Nicht alles, was hinkt, ist ein Vergleich.
Das stimmt, aber ich denke...
Aber es kann tatsächlich jedes Mal ein anderer Server sein. Und das, was eben da für die Endkunden angeboten wird, das wird genauso für die Route Name Server gemacht und für andere Dienste. Das heißt, ich habe mehrere Server und das heißt auch Attacken, die da gefahren werden, treffen immer nur regional beschränkt bestimmte Server. Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt eine verteilte, die Not-of-Service-Attacke habe, das heißt, ganz viel Traffic wird dahin geschickt.
Das heißt also, irgendjemand hat mehrere Rechner übernommen?
Irgendjemand hat da mehrere tausend Rechner übernommen und schickt einfach Unsinnstaten dahin, um den Dienst zu überlasten. Und die kommen jetzt beispielsweise, das ist ja gerade hip, alle aus Russland. Und ich habe jetzt so einen Route Name Server, der in Russland steht, mit dieser IP-Adresse in die Cast. Dann bleibt der Traffic quasi in Russland, weil der Server ist halt da in der Nähe.
Auch wenn sie weltweit verteilt wäre, die Attacke, ist das halt weniger schlimm, wenn du auch weltweit verteilt bist. Dann skalierst du einfach mit gegen deine Attacke und die ist nicht mehr so schlimm.
Das heißt letztendlich, wenn jemand versucht mit russischen Servern, einen DNS-Server, der entsprechend so aufgebaut ist, zu verteilen, dann leidet hauptsächlich die russische Bevölkerung darunter. Oder was immer sich Russland netztopologisch am nächsten fühlt.
Und die Roadname-Server-Betreiber gehen darauf auch ein, wenn sie sehen, da haben sie ein Problem, irgendwo da bräuchte man noch ein, zwei mehr, dann stellen sie da halt ein, zwei mehr einfach mit hin.
Okay, aber ist Anycast etwas, was man jetzt nur, wir sind jetzt extra in die Untiefen des DNS-Systems abgestiegen, um das zu erklären.
Das hat auch einen Grund.
Okay, dann das wollte ich gerade fragen, warum machen wir das jetzt anhand von DNS?
DNS ist ein Dienst, der normalerweise, wenn alles so gut läuft und nicht irgendwelche Spezialfälle eintreten, eigentlich immer UDP benutzt.
So tief brauchen wir gar nicht einsteigen. Du schickst einem DNS-Server eine kleine Anfrage und er schickt dir eine kleine Antwort zurück und ihr baut da keine Verbindung auf. Wenn ich zu einem Webserver, wo ich meine Webseite abrufe, mit dem sprechen möchte, dann bau ich zu dem eine Verbindung auf und die kann eine Weile brauchen. Wenn ich zum Beispiel einen Download mache, dann kann der über eine Stunde gehen. Und wenn sich da dann in der Zwischenzeit die Netztopologie verändert und plötzlich ein anderer Server für dich attraktiver wird von der Ernährung im Netz, dann würde deine Verbindung abbrechen, weil der andere Server natürlich von der Verbindung nichts weiß. Bei DNS ist es so, du schickst eine Frage hin, du kriegst ein Paket mit einer Antwort zurück und dann ist gut. Deswegen eignet sich das für so Anycast ganz hervorragend.
Genau, um das ganz kurz zur Vollständigkeit zu halten, das UDP ist das ohne Verbindung und das TCP ist das mit Verbindung, das könnte man jetzt schon mal gehört haben.
Anycast haben wir gesagt, das andere, wo es irgendwie noch vorteilhaft ist, irgendwie ins gesamte Internet sprechen zu können, sind CDNs. Das heißt, das sind?
Das sind Leute, die sowas wie Anycast Netze betreiben, mit noch Magie da drüber und wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel sagt, zum Beispiel sind der CCC und wir haben jetzt hier monatlich ein Software releasen, das muss auf alle Rechner in der Welt ganz, ganz schnell kommen.
Nein, nein, nein. Oder angenommen.
Angenommen würden wir regelmäßig CCC.de updaten und die Leute klicken da drauf.
Da ist aber nicht so viel Content drauf, da rentiert sich das nicht.
Genau, z.B. jetzt jemand so was wie, nimm mal eine große deutsche Newsseite. Und die muss natürlich schnell laden, von überall. Wenn man jetzt einen Server davon nach Deutschland stellt, dann legt der halt aus Amerika so ein bisschen zäh. Und aus Afrika gar nicht. Wirklich schnell. Und dann kann man sagen so, naja klar, dann stellen wir halt einen Server nach Afrika und einen Server nach Amerika, aber du willst das in der Regel dann nicht selbst betreiben, außer du bist halt wirklich ein Netzwerkmensch oder so.
Das heißt irgendwie, das ist für den Zweck gut, dass du jedes ADHS-Eichhörnchen auf der Welt zufriedenstehen willst, dass das irgendwie ungeduldig wird, wenn nach 10 Millisekunden die Webseite nicht da ist.
Oder du einfach mal riesige Dateien ausliefern musst, wie zum Beispiel ein Update für dein Telefon. Und wenn das jetzt jeder von einem Server zieht, der mit Gigabit am Internet hängt, dann ist das eine langwierige Sache, bis dein Telefon geupdatet ist. Also gibst du einen Koffer voll Geld und einen Koffer voll Daten zu einem sogenannten CDN, was ein Content Delivery Network ist, deren Geschäftszweck ist es sozusagen, Daten an allen Ecken und Enden der Welt eben schnell bereitzustellen, sodass sich keiner beschwert.
Gibt es außerdem noch Use Cases von CDNs?
Also zum Beispiel Media, CCC, CDE liegt auf dem CDN, weil sonst hätten wir nur einen Rechner, an dem das Ganze hängt, und der wäre vielleicht mal überlastet nach dem Kongress. Aber mit so einem CDN kann man das halt einfach mal auf diversen Rechner an diversen Standorten verteilen.
Und du kannst bei so einem CDN auch noch andere Dienste kaufen, sowas wie, naja, wir haben diese Daten, aber die braucht man nur so zweimal im Jahr. Also miete ich halt für diese Zeiträume, in denen ich die Daten halt wirklich anbieten möchte, die Ressourcen beim CDN. Du musst halt nicht selber weltweit Server hinstellen, weil das wäre halt die Alternative. Ich kaufe mir halt ein paar Hundert Server oder miete die irgendwo in irgendwelchen, ja, so Hostern und mache das alles selber. Es ist halt Aufwand und das ist schwierig. Und dann muss ich wissen, wo sind eigentlich meine Kunden und wie viele Kunden habe ich da und ich kann so schnell gar nicht reagieren. Und nach zwei Monaten brauche ich das alles nicht mehr. Ist halt einfacher, dann da jemanden zu beauftragen, der sich damit auskennt.
Das heißt, wenn ich irgendwie temporär skalieren muss, ist das eine Möglichkeit, jetzt nicht eigene Hardware anzuschaffen, sondern einfach mal kurzfristig zu sagen, hier, mein Download-Server, der schafft das eigentlich. Die meiste Zeit, aber jetzt in den zwei Wochen, schaff ich das nicht alleine.
Ich hab jetzt hier eine super tolle neue App gebaut und die wird jetzt auf allen Newsportalen nächste Woche gehypt oder nächsten Monat. Vielleicht bereite ich mich da schon mal drauf vor und kauf dann für diesen einen Monat da ein bisschen Ressourcen bei so einem CDN.
Und es gibt dann auch den Fall, dass man eben ein Businessmodell hat, was einfach mit vielen Usern klarkommen muss, wie soziale Netzwerke und so weiter. Da lohnt es sich dann tatsächlich selber, so ein CDN zu bauen und weltweit zu verteilen.
Das heißt, so was wie ein Facebook betreibt sein CDN auch durchaus selber?
Genau.
Was sind denn so CDN-Anbieter? Kennt man die so normalerweise?
Die kennt man vielleicht, wenn man in seinem Browser ganz aufmerksam in die Adressleiste geguckt hat. Weil manchmal sieht man dann tatsächlich, dass der Content, den man da guckt, nicht mehr von der eigentlichen Seite kommt, sondern dass zum Beispiel ein Download-Link von irgendeinem dieser CDN-Betreiber eben kommt.
Oder dass das Leiste Haus bei Akamai liegt, glaube ich. Also die Webseite vom Weißen Haus liegt halt auch in so einem CDN mit drin. Und wenn man dann so die HTTPS-Verbindung aufbaut, poppt dann da plötzlich ein komischer Name im Zertifikat auf.
Hausten unsere Öffentlich-Rechtlichen eigentlich zum Beispiel selber oder lassen die das auch machen?
Also ich glaube, Bundestag zum Beispiel liegt auch gerade auf einem CDN.
Bundestag liegt gerade auf einem CDN, aber Öffentlich-Rechtliche waren jetzt die so ZDF-ID. Ich glaube ZDF, die Mediathek liegt definitiv auf dem CDN.
Ja, das hat aber für die eine Firma selber gebaut, glaube ich.
Ja, das war ein Custom-Geklöppel, das ist.
Das Problem, die Sache bei einer Mediathek für Öffentlich-Rechtliche in Deutschland ist auch, dass deine Zielgruppe nicht geodivers ist, sondern dass die Zielgruppe halt in Deutschland ist. Und da reicht es aus, wenn man eben in Europa ein paar Server stehen hat. Während wenn du jetzt sowas wie bundestag.de oder so hast, dann...
Also bundestag.de nimmt es wahrscheinlich zum Beispiel aus einem anderen Grund. Also CDNs ist halt der eine Punkt, wo du halt datenschnell liefern willst. Aber ein CDN ist auch zum Beispiel ein super Ding, um sich hinter zu verstecken. Weil wenn jetzt mein Server plattgemacht wird mit einer Attacke, dann soll die das mal bitte beim CDN versuchen, was ein paar Tausend Server hat.
Das ist genau das Ding. Also ein CDN ist dafür da, wie du schon sagst, Daten schnell auszuliefern. Und so eine normale Denial-of-Service-Attacke zum Beispiel, wo der Angreifer es darauf ansetzt, den Server durch Anfragen zu überlasten, funktioniert genauso, dass da viele Anfragen gestellt werden, wenn man dann so ein CDN hat, was einfach viele Anfragen beantworten kann.
Ist das eine Verschwörungstheorie, wenn ich sage, dass man sich so ein Business Case für ein CDN selber bauen kann?
Das nennt sich nicht Verschwörung, sondern Vertrieb.
Also das ist tatsächlich so eine schöne Webseite, die sie da haben. Wäre doch schade, wenn der...
Naja, auf der anderen Richtung gibt es das Geschäftsmodell gerade sehr aktiv. Das heißt, ich habe halt so meinen Webshop oder so was. Vielleicht ist auch nicht so ein ganz großes Unternehmen, das so viel Geld hat, so ein CDN-Anbieter zu beauftragen. Nehmen wir mal an, ich bin da irgendwie so mein Webshop, der gerade so gut läuft. Und dann kriege ich halt so eine E-Mail so, wir machen jetzt mal für eine Stunde übrigens gleich der Webshop platt und wir zeigen dir, dass das geht. Und wenn du uns jetzt nicht Geld überweist, mehr oder weniger regelmäßig, machen wir das jetzt halt auch häufiger. Und du kriegst halt dann so eine DINAROUS-SERVICE-ATTACKE, die läuft dann irgendwie 10 Minuten bis eine Stunde oder so. Du kriegst Panik, weil es funktioniert nichts mehr. Dann liest du diese E-Mail und hast halt einen ganz klassischen Erpressungsfall.
Und dann habe ich letztendlich die Wahl, zahle ich oder nehme ich für möglicherweise etwas weniger Geld die Dienste von so einem CDN in Anspruch.
Das Problem, das hört man mich noch, das Problem, an dem zahle ich, das hört halt dann nicht auf, wie das bei Erpressungen so üblich ist. Weil das hat einmal funktioniert, warum soll es nicht zweimal funktionieren? Oder dreimal oder fünfmal?
Mit Mengen, Robert.
Genau. Das heißt, wir haben gelernt, es gibt sehr, sehr viele Anwendungsfälle für CDNs. Und im Endeffekt ist es alles nur dazu da, dass ich, wenn ich zu Hause hinter meinem kleinen DSL-Router sitze, mit dem wir vor etwas mehr als eineinhalb Viertelstunden angefangen haben, irgendwie zuverlässig irgendwie YouTube gucken kann.
Genau. Das ist allerdings jetzt auch noch mal ein anderer Spezialfall. Es gibt nicht nur diese statischen CDNs, wo ich dann sage, ich hab hier meinen Content, ich geb dir eine Festplatte oder ich gruppier den da auf einen Server bei dir. Es gibt auch noch diese dynamischen Sachen, wie gerade eben aus YouTube angesprochen, das macht. YouTube gehört ja zu Google und die haben dann Google Caches, die durchaus auch mal bei den Provider stehen. Also ich hab also eine Bewegung, die immer näher zum Endkunden geht. Wir hatten vorher gesagt, ich hab das CDN, weil es mir nicht viel bringt, einen Server nur in Deutschland zu haben, wenn das aus den USA abgerufen wird. Also habe ich das CDN mit den Servern, die auch in den USA stehen. Der nächste Schritt ist eben, ich stelle diese Zwischenschweicher, diese Caches eben direkt in das Provider-Netzwerk, in den Backbone von meinem ISP, wo die ganzen Endkunden dran sind.
Machen die großen CDNs tatsächlich auch?
Genau, darauf wollte ich halt genau raus.
Ich dachte, es ginge immer nur darum, ein gutes Peering, also eine gute Verbindung mit denen zu haben.
Naja, das beste Peering ist, wenn du das Ding den Leuten in die eigene Hütte stellst.
Gut, das stimmt natürlich.
Also wenn du zum Beispiel in Deutschland was betreibst und du hast so CDNs und dann hast du halt nicht nur 1 Gigabit, sondern so 200 Gigabit zu dem CDN und wieso jetzt den gesamten Traffic erst mal nach Frankfurt und Düsseldorf transportieren, wenn du auch jeweils 20 Gigabit in jeder kleinen Stadt haben kannst, wo du ein bisschen mehr Technik hast.
Also ich hätte jetzt tatsächlich gedacht, dass der Traffic, der so ausgeliefert wird, so divers ist, dass sich so ein lokaler Cash mit begrenztem Speicher nicht lohnt. Ja, es ist wirklich so, dass alle Leute nur Cat-Content gucken und über das eine Video...
Das ist die Magie, die ich am Anfang erwähnte. Wenn man einfach sagen könnte, hier sind Daten und verteile mal, dann würde das halt jeder machen. Aber tatsächlich gibt es halt große CDNs, die wirklich viel benutzt werden, weil diese Magie einfach stimmt. Das ist dann halt eine ganz große Kombination aus Sachen wie, wo sitzt der User, was braucht er für Content, welche Rechtsregionen passt dahin, wie viel kostet der Strom, wo die Daten verfügbar sind, wie viel kostet der Traffic dahin zum Provider, ist die Strecke niedrig hochlatent, ist sie schnell oder langsam, ist da Packet loss oder nicht, wie wichtig ist der Content. Da spielen halt 25.000 Sachen mit rein, wo dann bei so großen CDNs entschieden wird, dahin wird der Traffic jetzt also von diesem Punkt wieder ausgeliefert. Und da ist halt die Präferenz natürlich bei diesen Servern, die halt direkt im Backbone stehen, aber du kannst ja so einen Server auch nicht endlos befüllen. Und dann gibt es wiederum sogenannte Algorithmen dafür, die sich dann darum kümmern, dass immer der richtige Content mit der besten Success-Hitrate sozusagen auf diesen Servern liegt. Also Hitrate ist das halt, dass man sagt, da versuchen wir so viel möglich dran zu haben. Und es bringt halt jetzt nichts irgendwie, zum Beispiel, wenn in Deutschland ein Apple-Update released wird, dann muss das Apple-Update halt auf den Servern gerade liegen an dem Moment. Und das Microsoft-Update von vor einer Woche ist dann halt weniger interessant oder halt andersrum. Beziehungsweise, ich weiß nicht, wenn die Queen spricht, ist das jetzt für Deutschland weniger interessant. Also muss man das jetzt nicht unbedingt so auf deutschen Servern abwickeln, aber dafür richtig viel auf englischen Servern.
Das Ganze wird dann noch komplexer, wenn du eine bestimmte Dienstgüte zusichern möchtest für einen Download zum Beispiel. Da bringt es dir dann wenig, wenn du alle Teilnehmer auf den jeweils lokalen Node legst. Wenn das ein längerer Download ist, dann kannst du aber sagen, wenn der zu so und so voll ist, dann geht es um den zweitschlechteren, weil der immer noch eine höhere Datenrate liefert als der erste. Also da steckt ganz viel den Content und die User kennen, unser Netz kennen und das in Korrelation setzen.
Zwei Fragen. Erstens, möchte man überhaupt noch größere Dienste ohne ein CDN betreiben?
Ja, kommt auf den Dienst an. Also sagt den Dienst und ich sag dir das, aber weißt jetzt nicht, müsste man halt Case by Case entscheiden. Ich kann jetzt nicht pauschal sagen, so wie...
Ganz spannender Fall, Voice over IP.
Ja.
Das kannst du nicht ins CDN?
Ja, absolut, weil das eine 1 zu 1 Verbindung ist. Nee, aber das klingt jetzt so, wenn ich quasi in so einer Broadcast-Situation bin, das heißt ich zu, zum Rest der Welt, was ja eigentlich, ich denke mal, bei den meisten Diensten der Normalfall ist und irgendwie eine gewisse Wichtigkeit erreicht habe, dass ich dann eigentlich um so ein CDN nicht drum rumkomme. Egal, ob selbst betrieben, also die spannende Frage ist wahrscheinlich auch nochmal, kann ich mir, oder könnte ich mir, es ist natürlich immer noch die Frage, dass man Leute hat, die sowas betreiben. Wir haben gerade gehört, der CCC hat irgendwie selber ein CDN am Start für Videos. Das heißt, es scheint auch selber zu gehen, aber will ich in der Regel diese Magic haben?
Sie kosten natürlich am Ende in der Regel Geld. Also da muss ich halt wirklich hinsetzen und sage es halt so, ist mir diese Magic und diese mehr User Experience das wert oder merken das meine User eh nicht, weil die surfen nur aus Berlin oder die haben eh nur 56k Modems, brauchen die es überhaupt schnell?
Oder ist es okay, wenn der Download halt irgendwie fünf Minuten länger dauert bei dem Video, was drei Stunden geht? Bei so einer Organisation wie dem CCC ist das jetzt nicht so geschäftskritisch, dass die Leute sich den Stream oder den Podcast ein bisschen später runterladen, weil sie sowieso die Videos alle vom Kongress ziehen, während so ein Software Update vielleicht schon ein bisschen kritischer ist, weil ich das nicht möchte, dass sich das ewig hinzieht und dauernd abrichtend Leute neu versuchen, weil da wären sie böse und dann sind sie sauer auf meine Firma und dann kaufen sie mein Produkt nicht mehr.
Man muss da aber auch mal unsere User loben, ihr zieht euch das ja eh auch über betorrent. Brauchen wir gar kein CDN.
Wobei unser CDN tatsächlich auch betorrent Support hat, wenn ich mich richtig entsinne. Das heißt, wenn du eine Datei runterlätst, Achtung, Nordalarm wieder, du kriegst die nächsten Download-Server dann als HTTP Seats.
Das heißt, dein betorrent client spricht nicht nur dieses esoterische Hacker-betorrent-Protokoll, sondern auch das HTTP.
Genau, und dann kannst du dir quasi, solange betorrent tot rostet, das ist ja gerade am Anfang immer der Fall, wenn wir jetzt zum Beispiel gleich fertig sind, plus die Zeit, die wir brauchen, um die Sendung hier zu schneiden, dann damit die ersten dann quasi trotzdem ganz schnell herunterladen können, auch wenn auch niemand anders da per betorrent Sachen raushaut, können sie halt immer noch ihre nächsten Download-Server mit reinnehmen. Das ist eigentlich eine ziemlich coole Lösung.
Jetzt haben wir also gesprochen, wie wir skalieren können, wenn wir Daten verteilen wollen, aber jetzt habe ich eigentlich noch mal kurz eine Frage dazu, die kommt aus dem Publikum mehr oder weniger.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob die zu nerdig ist, aber z.B. man hat ja z.B. so eine Webseite, wo z.B. Webmail liegt oder ein Webshop und da ist ja immer dieses HTTPS und so ein grünes Schlüsselding davor. Will man dann diesen Private Key, also sozusagen deinen Schlüssel, um das ganze Krypto aufzumachen, will man den dann so auf 1000 Servern in der Welt bei einem Drittanbieter liegen haben?
Das ist eine hervorragende Frage, will man eigentlich nicht. Aber das Weißhaus macht das, die vertrauende Ackermai. Wenn ich jetzt so einen CDN habe, was nur Daten verteilt, dann komme ich da so ein bisschen drum rum, weil der Download-Server hat eine andere URL, die kann ein Certifikat haben mit einem eigenen Key, hat mit meiner Webseite nicht viel zu tun. Der Webshop wird ja meistens auch irgendwie eine zentrale Instanz haben, weil das auf einen CDN zu packen ist jetzt nicht so trivial, weil dann landen Leute dann auf einem anderen Server und das ist dann doof und dann habe ich keine zentrale Buchhaltung und das geht alles kaputt. Das heißt, da hat man sowieso andere Maßnahmen davor. Und ich glaube Nibbler explodiert hier gleich. Du hast da gerade eben ganz, ganz viel geschüttelt.
Da hatte ich zum Glück den Keks noch im Mund.
Ansonsten ist das natürlich ein Problem. Ich kann natürlich verschiedene Zertifikate mit verschiedenen Keys haben. Das heißt, man kann dann immer nur die eine Verbindung aufmachen. Aber das ist natürlich dann eine Überlegung, die man sich machen muss. Ich glaube, da gab es jetzt auch gerade Diskussionen, dass der Bundestag.de gerade hinter Cloud für glaub ich ist. Das ist ein amerikanischer Anbieter für die CDNs und DDoS Protection. Und wenn man da TPS drüber spricht, dann können die natürlich die Daten alle mitlesen.
Cloudflare.
Jetzt diffamieren unsere amerikanischen Freunde nicht so.
Und jetzt müssen wir auch wieder andere Namen nennen, weil es gibt halt auch noch andere CDNs. Wenn ihr mal nachsuchen wollt, was sie zum Beispiel machen.
Limelight?
Gibt's Limelight, Akamai, Cloudflare hatten wir jetzt. Wen haben wir noch? Ich glaube, ich sollte mehr kennen.
Ja, ich sehe schon Kai. Wir sollten es halt jetzt über Auftrag nennen, definitiv.
Nee, ich mach nur das, was der Markus macht, weil der fällt dann ja auch ins Wort.
Ja, ich muss das hier nicht machen, weil wir senden hier nicht auf Fritz.
Ja, aber dann ist CCC wieder irgendwie befürwortend für andere und wir machen eine Empfehlung.
Und ich bin Angestellter des Landes Berlin, ich muss darauf passen.
Vorbildlich. Ja, das heißt, jetzt haben wir einmal die CDNs durchgekaut.
Na, aber es gibt ja noch was anderes.
Aha, das wäre jetzt mal eine Frage gewesen. Sind wir fertig?
Du hattest ja früh mit der Cloud angefangen. Ich würde jetzt noch nicht CDNs direkt als Cloud bezeichnen, weil Cloud ist normalerweise so vom Verständnis her ein bisschen nur was anderes.
Was sind die Cloud?
Die Cloud sind Computer von anderen Leuten.
So, und kleiner Vorschlag, wir spielen jetzt eine kleine Musik.
Voll dafür.
Und dann beschäftigen wir uns zum einen noch damit, was eigentlich jetzt genau die Cloud sonst noch ist, außer CDNs. Und wir schauen mal nach, wenn das Internet wackelt, woran kann das eigentlich liegen? Das hören wir gleich. Ich glaube es ist Zeit, die Tür abzulegen. So, willkommen zurück in der letzten halben Stunde Chaosradio 213. Das war Magna mit Divide. Das ist Netzmusik, die ihr euch runterladen könnt. Ich denke, die werden wir gleich noch in den Show Notes verlinken.
Von dem CDN?
Von einem CDN vermutlich und der, der da reinquatscht, das ist der Mutax.
Hallo.
Dann haben wir noch den Nibbler.
Und den Kai. Hallo. So.
Ich unterbrech dich an der Stelle mal mit einem großartigen Witz.
Oh Gott.
Give me a strong cider please because I'm exhausted. Die nächste halbe Stunde sollten wir mit einem Thema füllen können.
Ich glaube auch. Hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo. Ich glaube, ich muss wieder den Markus holen.
Herzlich willkommen beim Chaosradio.
So. Ich will hier raus.
Kommst du nicht.
Mist. Aber das Schöne ist ja, als Moderator kann ich euch verpflichten, Dinge zu erklären. Und der Mutaxe hat sich gerade bereit erklärt. Es hat aber wunderbar funktioniert. Wir haben eineinhalb Stunden voll bekommen. So, und die letzte machen wir auch noch, weil der Mutaxe erklärt uns jetzt, warum CDNs nicht alles sind, wenn wir von Cloud reden. So, bitte.
Ja, Cloud sind ja wie gesagt anderer Leute Computer. Und das sind jetzt nicht Kühlschränke.
Gibt es auch schon ziemlich lange. Früher hat man das Mainframe genannt.
Genau. Mainframe ist halt dann so der Zentralrechner. Und irgendwie gehen wir so langsam wieder in diese Richtung zurück. Wir haben jetzt so unsere kleinen Taschencomputer, die nur noch so ein Frontend mit einer App sind für einen Großrechner. Und das Problem ist, dass so ein einzelner Großrechner hinter nicht mehr reicht, wir haben ja, wie du gesagt hast, der Webshop im CDM, das funktioniert halt nicht so ganz, weil der Webshop ist halt eine aktive Anwendung. Und wenn ich die verteile und die Leute dauernd auf einen anderen Server kommen, gehen halt Sachen kaputt. Das heißt, ich muss meine Anwendung halt so bauen, dass sie skaliert über mehrere Server hinweg. Dann habe ich aber auch wieder das Problem, naja, eigene Server kaufen ist halt doof, weil mein Webshop wird halt nicht 24 mal 7 immer komplett benutzt, weil ich habe halt irgendwie so Geschäftszeiten vielleicht.
Ladenöffnungszeiten.
Genau, vielleicht verkaufe ich ja auch irgendwie erotischen Inhalt, dann darf ich das erst ab 22 Uhr in Deutschland machen. Dann brauche ich tagsüber den Webshop ja gar nicht. Und so habe ich halt verschiedene Lastkurven auf meinen Servern drauf. Und immer für die maximale Last alle Ressourcen bereitzuhalten, ist halt auf Dauer relativ teuer. Das braucht Strom, das braucht Platz. Und im Zuge dieser ganzen Virtualisierungsgeschichten, die es in den letzten Jahren immer mehr gab, kam halt dann auch irgendwann so was wie die Cloud. Die Cloud ist halt ganz wolkig, weil man kann da nicht durchgucken, man sieht ja nicht genau was passiert, aber am Ende kommt da unten Wasser raus. Und man kann jetzt behaupten, na okay, das heißt die Daten der anderen regnen so auf alle Leute, wenn die Cloud undicht ist, weil dann sind die halt Daten so verteilt überall. Das ist die eine Geschichte, aber eigentlich ist es so für mich als Anbieter relativ praktisch, weil ich bezahle eventuell so einen Cloud-Dienstleister nach so einer Metrik wie ich bezahle nur die CPU-Zeit, die ich wirklich brauche und wenn mein Webshop gerade nicht gebraucht wird, dann ist da auch kein Server, der den irgendwie laufen lässt, weil ich habe einen physikalischen Rechner, auf dem ich dann hunderte virtuelle Maschinen habe und jeder dieser Maschinen gehört dann irgendeinem anderen Kunden. Und damit kann ich halt sehr schnell skalieren, wenn ich plötzlich solche Loadpeaks habe, wie zum Beispiel zu Silvester verschicken die Leute ganz, ganz viele SMS und dann brauche ich ganz viele Server, die die SMS handeln, den Rest des Jahres kann ich benutzen um meine Rechnungen zu schreiben und andere Dinge zu tun für die ich vielleicht mehr brauchen kann. Und dann komme ich eben in den Bereich dieser Cloud Dienstleister und das ist für Start-ups auch eine schöne Möglichkeit natürlich. Ich habe dann irgendwie meine geile Applikation, so mein Cloud Backup oder sowas, und plötzlich werde ich dann von Kunden überrannt und brauche ganz viel Speicher und ganz viel Server und dann sind da plötzlich ganz viele in den USA, neue Kunden von mir. Jetzt kann ich da aber nicht einfach so Server hinstellen, habe da auch keine Leute. Also klicke ich mir dann in irgendeinem Cloud Provider meine virtuellen Maschinen zusammen und sage halt, ich brauche jetzt noch 500 mehr, weil ich habe plötzlich ganz viele Kunden dazugekommen. Und wenn meine Applikation das kann, dann skaliert das vielleicht sogar auch.
Aber eine wirkliche Garantie, da fange ich jetzt direkt mal an, eine wirkliche Garantie, dass meine Daten irgendwie datenschutzrechtlich nicht sicher sind, das lassen wir mal ganz völlig.
Das ist nochmal eine ganz andere Sache.
Aber mal abgesehen davon, genau, wie sicher kann ich denn überhaupt sein, dass quasi der Teil meiner Maschine, auf den ich da zeitlich und auch sonst wie Zugriff habe, wirklich meiner ist und war?
Genau. Man kann auch so schöne Kardinalsfehler machen. Es passiert ja ab und zu mal, dass so ein Cloud-Provider teilweise ausfällt. Und ich muss jetzt gerade wieder so ein konkretes Beispiel nehmen. So Amazon, die EC2 Cloud, hat da verschiedene Verfügbarkeitszonen. Ich kann halt sagen, ich möchte irgendwie in Nordamerika verfügbar sein oder ich möchte auch in Europaserver haben oder in Asien oder sowas. Und vielleicht möchte ich auch Ausfallsicherheit haben. Die muss ich aber extra bezahlen und dazu buchen. Und wenn ich dann so eine Start-up-Firma bin, die Herzpatienten überwacht und ihre Herzdaten aufbereitet, damit Ärzte darauf zugreifen können, ist es nicht so eine ganz gute Idee, wenn ich nur eine Verfügbarkeitszone buche und die dann ausfällt.
Warte, warte, warte. Da gibt es wirklich Leute, die wichtige medizinische Dienste auf Amazon laufen lassen.
Amerika. Und der Arzt kann halt dann im Webinterface gucken, wie es seinen Patienten so geht und welche davon kurz vor einem Herzanfall stehen und kann dann jemanden vorbeischicken oder gucken, wie es denen geht.
Hoffentlich nur der Arzt.
Hoffentlich nur der Arzt, vielleicht auch nicht.
Und der Admin von der EC2.
Es ist ja alles harmlos, weil man möchte ja, dass da jemand vorbeikommt, bevor der tot ist. Das Problem war halt nur, es gab dann so dieses Supportforum und da hat dann jemand sehr, sehr aufgeregt drin geschrieben, könnt ihr das nicht machen, dass die Cloud-Plattform ganz schnell wieder da ist, weil wir wissen nicht, ob unsere Patienten noch leben.
Gut, das heißt...
Ist aber im Grunde dasselbe wie auch bei klassischer Rechenzentrumsplanung. Da hat man zwei Stromleitungen in seinen Rack rein, wenn man die Server nur an die eine anschließ. Oder die eine Hälfte an die eine, die andere Hälfte an die andere. Und nicht die zwei Netzteile, die da renundant im Server drin. Eins links, eins rechts. An die Stromleitungen. Also wann immer man Infrastruktur plant, sollte man sich halt mal angucken, das worauf ich das baue. Was kann das leisten? Und dass das, was es leisten kann, mir genug für das, was ich an Dienst anbieten möchte.
Das heißt so, dass das Takeaway von dieser Sache ist, ich muss unterscheiden. Davon bin ich sowieso nicht ausgegangen. Aber die zwei wichtigen Sachen. Erstens, planen muss ich, egal ob ich Cloud mache oder nicht. Das ist einfach Admin-Pflicht, meine Infrastruktur vorher sorgfältig zu planen, auch auf mögliche Ausfälle hin. Und das andere ist, Datensicherheit in der Cloud ist in mehrfacher Hinsicht ein Problem.
Du hast auch noch ein ganz, ganz schönes anderes Problem bei dieser ganzen Cloud, ist auch schon vorgekommen. Es gibt dann da so Anbieter, die bieten dir ganz, ganz sicheres Hosting für Source Code oder für deine Daten an. Und dann gibt es dann da so einen Admin, der dann da so sein Passwort eventuell versehentlich veröffentlicht. Oder wie auch immer bekommt jemand Zugriff auf dieses eine Webinterface von dem Cloud-Anbieter. Und da gibt es diesen großen roten Knopf Shutdown oder Delete. Und dann ist halt alles weg und weg ab auch. Und dann gibt es auch diese Firma nicht mehr. Auch vorgekommen.
Also auch das, auch da nur weil man irgendwas in die Cloud abgibt.
In der Cloud kann ich die Sachen auch sehr, sehr schnell und effizient löschen. Das ist halt der Vorteil von Virtualisierung. Im Gegensatz zu physikalischer Hardware. Da muss ich mit dem Hammer draufhauen oder auf jeden Server einzeln gehen. Wenn ich jetzt nicht so ein zentrales Konfigurationsmanagement habe. Bei der Cloud ist das halt ein Klick.
Also im Zweifelsfall ist es dann auch nur für mich gelöscht. Und die falschen Leute können immer noch drauf zugreifen.
Gut, umgekehrt möchtest du halt auch nicht, dass du da Daten hast und wenn sie gelöscht markiert sind. Kommt auch vor.
Kommt absolut bestimmt auch vor.
Löschen setzt doch eh nur das Flagg für deleted auf true in der Datenmark, oder?
Es geht doch auch kein Andelit mehr. Bei Gmail kann ich meine Mails jetzt auch 15 Sekunden lang wieder zurückziehen.
So, wälz weiter dumm, ich laber, darf die nächste Sendung moderieren. So, haben wir noch irgendwas wichtiges zur Cloud vergessen? Wahrscheinlich könnten wir da auch wieder ein ganzes Thema zu aufmachen. Der was bitte?
Der Fockcomputing.
Der Nebel, das ist noch undurchsichtiger.
Kannst du das anreißen, ohne dass wir da wieder ein halbstündiges Element draus machen?
Das ist Marketing von einem großen deutschen Telekom Provider oder so. Nee, es gibt so Aufkleber, da steht das drauf.
Okay, dann lass uns da besser nicht genauer drauf eingehen.
Um das nochmal ganz kurz zusammenzufassen, wenn euch irgendjemand Wolken oder irgendetwas anderes verkauft, fragt mal lieber nach, was ihr da wirklich bekommt.
Genau, also es ist ein schwammiges Wort für ein nicht greifbares Produkt. Passt auf. So, dann ist natürlich noch die Frage, das Internet kann wackeln?
Das Internet kann wackeln.
Warum? Wir haben doch gelernt, das ist doch ganz toll. Wir haben das Internet organisiert in diese wunderschönen autonomen Systeme und die machen das unter sich aus. Ich will nur mal kaputulieren, was ich verstanden habe. Dann müsst ihr mir erklären, warum das trotzdem kaputt gehen kann. Also, ich habe diese schönen Autonomensysteme. Innerhalb des Autonomensystems kann ein Anbieter, der dieses Autonomensystem verwaltet, Mist bauen und untereinander erzählen die sich letztendlich nur, wer sie sind. Warum kann da jetzt was kaputt gehen?
Na, da sind halt immer Menschen beteiligt und Menschen machen Fehler.
Aha, und diese Fehler können... Also, das mit dem Bagger hatten wir ja durchaus schon.
Also auf so einer BGP-Session zum Beispiel, wo sich die Rechner gegenseitig miteinander unterhalten. Weil ich glaube, du spielst auf einen ganz bestimmten Ausfall an.
Ja, dann erzähl mir doch mal, was du glaubst, was ich meine.
Und zwar, das haben vielleicht Leute mitbekommen am 12.06. die kleine Outage mit Malaysia Telecom.
Okay, warte mal, was interessiert mich denn Malaysia? Ich bin noch hier und ich möchte irgendwie YouTube Sachen gucken, die irgendwie in den USA sind oder wie wir gelernt haben, möglicherweise auch direkt in die Ecke. Was interessiert mich Malaysia Telecom?
Wenn die Malaysia Telecom nämlich plötzlich sagt, das gesamte Internet ist bei mir, dann interessiert dich das schon.
Moment, erstens, warum tut sie das? Zweitens, warum darf sie das? Drittens, warum kann sie das?
Tja, das kann sich alles auf das Wort Filter reduzieren, glaube ich. Und zwar diese ganzen BGP-Sessions. Da wird erstmal so, im Standardfall wird da alles rausgeschmissen und alles angenommen, was drüber reinkommt. Um das Ganze jetzt damit halt nicht irgendwie ich hingehen kann und sage ich bin jetzt irgendwie Google, machst du in der Regel deinen Filter und sagst so, der Kai darf nur das mir schicken, was der Kai auch wirklich mir schicken darf. Und da baut man dann aus diesen Datenbanken, die es im Internet gibt, Filter zusammen, die halt wirklich sicherstellen, dass da nicht zum Beispiel ich plötzlich dir sage, ich hab das Internet bei mir, sondern du sagst, ich nehm nur genau das, was der Kai wirklich selbst hat. Und Malaysia Telekom hat zum Beispiel so das Internet von einem großen Carrier bezogen, der nicht so wirklich diese Filter-Sessions drauf hatte. Und Malaysia Telekom hat dann einen Konfigurationsfehler gemacht und hat dann dem großen Carrier erstmal gesagt, so hallo, ich hab hier das gesamte Internet. Und der große Carrier hat wegen den Filtern gesagt, so cool, du hast das ganze Internet, ich nehm das mal alles an und trag das bei mir ein und erzähl das auch noch allen anderen Leuten. Und so hat es dann dazu geführt, dass plötzlich mal für ein paar Minuten das gesamte Internet gedacht hat, alles ist bei Malaysia Telekom. Aber da ist es gar nicht.
Okay, abgesehen von diesen Filtern, gibt es da keine Mechanismen, gibt es da keine Tabelle, wo grob drin steht, wer was darf, wer was kann und was tatsächlich plausibel ist. Also gut, das sind natürlich auch Filter, aber ich könnte mir eine Authentifizierung da vorstellen.
Du baust dir deine Filter von da, wo du deine IP-Adresse herbekommst. Ganz am Anfang haben wir kurz diese RIPE erwähnt, wo man IP-Adressen beantragen kann. Und die sagen dann halt auch, wir geben jetzt diese IP-Adresse an dich zum Beispiel. Und dann tragen sie in eine Datenbank ein, dass du diese IP-Adresse benutzen darfst. Und du darfst auch anderen Leuten sagen, dass du sie benutzt. Und idealerweise aus dieser Datenbank, dieser großen Tabelle sozusagen, baut man dann diese Filter. Und ich sag dann, dass ich nur das von dir annehme, wo RIPE sagt, dass du das auch announcing darfst.
Das gibt es beim RIPE, aber es scheint es nicht weltweit zu geben.
Nee, das gibt es in ein paar Regionen. In ein paar Regionen nicht so wirklich. Aber es bringen halt die besten Filter nichts, wenn die Leute, die den Router administrieren, diese Filter nicht drauf werfen und das nicht checken, was sie annehmen.
Und letztendlich, ihr sagt mehr als Filter einbauen, ist da als Vorsichtsmaßnahme nicht zu machen. Und wir werden auch in Zukunft mit Schwankungen zu rechnen haben.
Na ja, es gibt da Bestrebungen, so einen Kram zu signieren und so weiter. Das ist allerdings... Na ja, wenn du halt nicht filterst, dann filterst du nicht. Wie du jetzt am Ende filterst und ob du das jetzt signiert machst oder unsigniert oder was auch immer, ist halt ein soziales Problem.
Also, warum sollten Leute solche Signaturen checken und prüfen, wenn sie es nicht mal schaffen, sich in Lister einzutragen vernünftig und das zu pflegen?
Es ist ja sehr lustig, dass solche Leute die Infrastruktur quasi der ganzen Welt... Vielleicht ist nicht nur die Cloud das einzige, was keine gute Idee ist, wenn ich mir das so anhöre.
Internet abschalten und was mit Holz machen. Eine ganz tolle Methode.
Und Menschen mit Facebook-Schneggern.
Aber Menschen vergessen sich dann...
Du guckst dir Technik näher an und je tiefer du dir Technik anguckst, desto mehr hast du Respekt davor, dass es überhaupt funktioniert.
Also das Internet ist ein riesiger Haufen an Netzwerken, wo es ein Wunder ist, dass es so tut, wie es heute noch tut, wenn man sich mal anschaut, dass alles auf diesem BGP-Protokoll basiert, was eigentlich ziemlich überarbeitet werden müsste, mal dringendst.
Okay, das heißt, es basiert alles auf Menschen. Das heißt, du willst mir tatsächlich sagen, das Internet steht da, weil sich ein Haufen Leute regelmäßig zum Saufen treffen.
Zum Beispiel, aber auch weil...
Das nennt sich dann Beering-Policy.
Weil einfach Leute Dinge daran tun. Der Haken an der Sache ist, dass an diesem Internet nicht 10 Leute sind oder 100. Und man sagt, man trifft sich jetzt mal alle und schließt sich im Hotel ein. Und dann hackt man und macht ein neues Protokoll, was viel sicherer ist. Sondern da sind mehrere 10.000 Leute oder 100.000 Leute involviert, die Teile von diesem Internet administrieren. Und da kann man halt schlecht sagen, so am 31.12. um 0 Uhr schalten wir jetzt mal BGP aus und machen das neue Routing-Protokoll 2.0 mit Cloud Beta sonst was an. Und dann wird alles awesome und alles stabil. Sondern man sieht ja schon bei V6, wie lange das dauert, bis sich das adaptiert. Also kann man da grob mal drüber nachdenken, wie lange das dauern würde, wenn jetzt alle Leute BGP ausschalten und was anderes anschalten müssten.
Wann war denn der letzte Wechsel, als das passiert war? EGP nach BGP?
Ich glaube, ich war da noch nicht dabei. Also es war vor langer, langer Zeit.
War das Internet noch klein genug, dass man das mal eben so machen konnte? Und das ist deutlich über 15 Jahre her.
Worauf ich eigentlich aber auch hinaus wollte, ist so ein bisschen, das ist sehr viel, also die Tatsache, dass das IP-Verkehr von A nach B oder überhaupt Internetverkehr von A nach B fließen kann, hat sehr viel mit Leuten zu tun, die bei Anbietern sitzen und miteinander reden, dass dieser Datenaustausch dann auch tatsächlich eingerichtet wird.
Das Ding nennt sich halt Community.
Das klingt halt so ein bisschen lustig in meinen Ohren, wenn man sich vergegenwärtigt, dass da natürlich auch Kohle im Spiel ist. Da dann das Wort Community zu nabbe zählt doch mal.
Du hast da ganz viele verschiedene Layer, die beteiligt sind. Dieser Kohle-Layer ist das Management, das ist da oben irgendwo drüber. Das Schöne ist, ich als Forscher bin ja nicht so der Operator-Typ, der da jetzt wirklich Netze betreiben hat. Ich versuche das ja alles nur zu verstehen. Wenn ich auf so Konferenzen fahre, dann sehe ich, wie das funktioniert. Das heißt, da kommen Leute zusammen, die arbeiten bei verschiedenen Providern oder Carry-On oder Telcos. Diese Jobs ändern sich. Ich bin heute mal bei der Firma A, morgen bei der Firma B. Aber ich behalte ja die Kontakte, ich kenne die ganzen Leute. Aus so persönlichen Beziehungen entstehen dann z.B. Peerings. Ich treffe mich bei so einer Konferenz und sitze abends beim Bier zusammen.
Oder in der Sauna.
Oder in der Sauna und stelle fest, wir sind doch im selben Data Center und tauschen viel Traffic aus, lass doch mal einen Peerings aufsetzen. Das ist eben genau das, wie auch diese IXPs, diese Net Exchange Points, am Anfang entstanden sind. Es haben sich Leute getroffen, die gemeint haben, lass mal irgendwie zusammenschalten. Und das funktioniert so ähnlich heute immer noch. Das ist in verschiedenen Ländern, funktioniert das verschieden gut. Die Konferenz, in der ich so gesehen habe, ist vor allem dieses Ride Meeting, was da ein paar Mal im Jahr stattfindet. Da ist das eigentlich eine ziemlich nette Atmosphäre immer. Die Leute sind sehr freundlich. Und auch wenn sie unterschiedliche Positionen vertreten, vertreten sie sie zum Teil im Namen ihrer Firma. Das ist allerdings auch relativ klar und das versteht auch jeder. Und beim nächsten Meeting hat er vielleicht seinen Arbeitgeber gewechselt und man kann wieder ganz anders miteinander reden und andere Agreements da irgendwie machen. Gleichzeitig kann das natürlich auch eine Gefahr bedeuten, wenn das nicht funktioniert und sich zwei Leute nicht grün senden. Weil dann kommt vielleicht kein Periodenzustand, obwohl das sinnvoll wäre.
Das heißt, es kann sein, dass auch bedeutende Provider nicht miteinander peeren, weil sich Leute nicht...
Ich mag das im Einzelfall nicht ausschließen, kann da aber jetzt konkret kein Beispiel nennen.
Spannend. Na gut. Dann würde ich euch eigentlich nochmal fragen, was haben wir noch vergessen?
Adressknappheit?
Stimmt. Na dann, Adressknappheit. Ich hab gehört... Du hast noch drei Minuten, um dich über Adressknappheit auszulassen.
Mehr Zeit als Adressen.
Weil du es angesprochen hast.
Du wolltest natt machen.
Ich will keinen natt, ich hab keinen natt. Also wir haben dieses Internet, um miteinander reden zu können, hat jedes Gerät eine IP-Adresse. Und diese IP-Adressen sind bald alle.
Die sind endlich so. Diese IPv4-Adressen, wo man eben 255 mögliche Zahlen hat an vier Stellen, die sind halt irgendwann alle. Das ist jetzt so passiert.
Na jetzt kann ich halt das machen, was ich zu Hause mache. Zu Hause habe ich halt auch mehrere Geräte in meinem Netzwerk.
Und hast V6 angemacht?
Moment, ich will dir erstmal das Böse erklären. Das, was alles kaputt macht. Und ich habe mehrere Geräte, aber mein Provider gibt mir auch nur eine, welche Verbindungen das sind und Stück für Karten zurückkommen. Das kann ich jetzt zu Hause auf meinem Plastikrouter machen. Das kann ich aber auch in größer machen. Wenn ich jetzt so ein Provider bin.
Mobilfunknetz?
Ja, Mobilfunknetz oder halt auch jetzt tatsächlich beim klassischen DSL oder Kabelmode. Ich habe halt mehr Kunden als IP-Adressen und die Kunden wollen alle gleichzeitig online sein. Dann mache ich halt das auch in groß. Das heißt, ich bekomme die Datenpakete von meinen Kunden, klatsche dann eine andere IP-Adresse da vorne davor und schicke das so weiter. Und dann muss ich dieser Router merken, wo das hergekommen ist und zurückschicken. Das heißt, ich habe jetzt aber plötzlich zweimal diese Adress-Translation, dieses NAT. Ich habe das einmal zuhause bei mir bei dem Plastikrouter und dann nochmal bei meinem Provider.
Und vor allen Dingen der Kunde, wenn ich das nicht verstehe, ist dann eigentlich gar nicht mehr richtig im Internet.
Genau, der Kunde ist dann hinter zweimal diesem NAT und wenn er dann versucht irgendwie Online-Spiele zu spielen, die auch eingehende Verbindungen brauchen, oder wenn er versucht, Google Maps aufzurufen, das sehr sehr viele Verwendungen parallel aufbaut.
Oder wenn er versucht, über das Internet zu telefonieren, was ihr eine dumme Idee ist, weil über das Internet kann man nicht telefonieren.
Genau, dann geht das halt alles plötzlich nicht mehr. Und die Kunden werden plötzlich unzufrieden. Auf der anderen Seite habe ich halt die Provider, die unheimlich viel Geld investieren in diese Care-Rate-Nuts, so heißen diese Gerätschaften, die das machen, die aber auch nicht glücklich werden damit, weil sie an einem Punkt geschlafen haben. Das war die Einführung von IPv6. Das Protokoll ist mittlerweile doch deutlich über einen Jahrzehnt alt.
Und es gibt da die ganz einfache Lösung, na gut, wenn uns die Adresse zu klein ist, dann machen wir die Adressen halt größer.
Genau. Und bei IPv6 haben wir halt genau das gemacht. Wir haben nicht mehr 32 Bit, sondern wir haben 128 Bit pro Adresse.
Wann kann ich das haben?
Jetzt, also seit über 10 Jahren.
Wann kann ich das wirklich haben?
Geht zum richtigen ISP. Also gleichzeitig gibt es Leute, die das ausrollen, als wäre es das Selbstverständlichste auf der Welt.
Und auf der anderen Seite?
Auf der anderen Seite gibt es Leute, die sehen da einen Berg Kosten, der da entgegenkommt, um die wieder reinzuholen, bauen kann und ob die Technik das nicht kann. Und man muss dann auch erstmal ganz viel Arbeit reinstecken, weil vor 10 Jahren war das ja nicht nötig, dass man das brauchte. Und jetzt drückt das und jetzt muss halt sowas schnell gebaut werden. Viel mehr Geld plötzlich.
Weil natürlich auch die ganzen Berater, die das können, jetzt ausgebucht sind.
Okay, ich sehe. Das ist also alles noch ganz, ganz traurig. Und ich glaube auch zu V6 können wir eigentlich noch mal eine eigene Sendung machen. Soweit erstmal danke an Kai, Nibler und Mutags. Dann jetzt zum Abschluss noch ein paar Hausmeistereien. Wir müssen eigentlich das Camp ankündigen. Nochmal ankündigen. Ich weiß, wir haben das schon ein paar Mal gemacht.
Findet das überhaupt statt, so ohne Tickets?
Gibt es da überhaupt Internet auf diesem Camp?
Ja, tatsächlich gibt es auf diesem Camp Internet. Wir werden uns das auf einer Hochspannungsleitung rausholen.
Das heißt, wir können uns freuen, dass auch hier wieder Infrastruktur benutzt wird, um Glasfaser in die Wallachie zu bringen. Nämlich nach Mildenberg, wo wir vom 13. bis zum 17. August im Ziegeleihepark das Chaos Communication Camp veranstalten werden. Vermutlich mit Internet, hoffentlich auch bald mit Tickets. Alles weitere dann unter events.ccc.de. Ansonsten haben wir natürlich noch anzukündigen, was wir immer haben, weitere Vorträge, wie Kai das jetzt gemacht hat. Die Reihe nennt sich Datengarten. Der nächste, mit der Nummer 55, findet am Dienstag den 14.07. ab 20 Uhr hier in diesen Räumen im CCCW statt. Ansonsten jeden zweiten Dienstag im Monat. Oder manchmal gibt es auch Termine außer der Reihe. Da könnt ihr dann den Twitter-Account at clubdiscordia oder der entsprechenden Mailingliste folgen. Schaut einfach mal vorbei, Berlin.ccc.de. In jedem Fall für euch die Anlaufstelle.
Das auch zweimal die Woche, nämlich Dienstags und Donnerstags beim clubdiscordia.
Genau, dort könnt ihr einfach vorbeischauen und Kontakt aufnehmen mit der restlichen Community, die hier so im Club rumschwirrt. Gut, und damit werden wir eigentlich am Ende der Sendung angelangt. Und mir bleibt nur noch zu sagen, macht's gut. Bis zum nächsten Mal, dann wieder auf Ritz mit Markus Richter.
Lasst euch nicht verschlüsseln und überwacht immer eure Backups.